[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to the dave ramsey show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios
it's the dave ramsey show where debt is
dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i
am dave ramsey your host anthony o'neil
ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five
five five for those of you that have
served or are serving happy veterans day
to you thank you
thank you thank you for what you do um
because of you we are
uh around here at ramsey we are under no
illusion that we have our freedoms
because you people exist
so thank you and uh those of you that
know a veteran
tell them i said thanks and anthony said
thanks absolutely
your dad is a marine right both of them
yeah my stepfather's a marine and my
biological father is our army okay yeah
that's the part
i miss the army part okay i remember the
marine but yeah yep yep yep my father
served in
camp pendleton and my biological father
served uh fort bragg cool yeah and our
debt-free screams today
will be from veterans oh man i can't
wait pretty cool this is amazing
pretty cool open phones at triple eight
eight two five five
two two five as we talk about your life
and your money
you jump in anthony and i are here to
help you with wherever you are
aidan is with us in nova scotia hi aidan
how are you
good how are you dave better than i
deserve sir what's up
love it uh so here's uh kind of a
breakdown of me i'm 24
i make 50k a year i'm debt debt-free on
step four
emergency fund and about 10 000 invested
so far
so the situation is my mother has lived
with no one else so that she can give
like no one else
unfortunately for me this means uh she's
offered 25 000 towards my first home
purchase
um the thing is before finding it so i
had a goal to buy my first host
in cash about 10 years from now so
obviously now i'm reconsidering my goals
of
in cash um so really what's the best
option here am i still
am i missing out on building wealth by
delaying that purchase and just having
25k
sitting there in the bank for five to
ten years or should i bite the bullet
now
with uh about a thirty forty thousand
dollars down payment
wow these are such problems to have so i
mean yeah how many i mean
you're in such good shape man oh well
done so this isn't
let me clarify for mom this is a gift
it is not alone yeah absolutely
okay okay all right and she's not
controlling and isn't going to come over
and question how you keep the house
after she gave you 25 grand
you know i love my mom and i hug her
every day for it i i wasn't questioning
whether you loved her i'd ask any if she
was controlling
it is your mom she's not is your mom
requiring to take 25 000
and buy a house today or can you stop
stack that from when you want to bet buy
one cash
uh no it doesn't have to be today but i
guess i'm worried that
i'm missing out on interest that i could
accumulate in
five to ten years yeah you you know if
she if she gave you the money now you
invested it
or if you if she gave the money now and
you bought a house on a 15-year fixed
where the payment's no more than a
fourth of your take-home pay
and you knock that out neither one of
these are in the dumb column
not at all they're both within the range
of quote approved
ramsey behaviors yes unquote
uh meaning common freaking sense so uh
yeah you
you're not gonna get over in the dumb
column with any of this it's just a
matter of how you feel about it
the thing i'm hearing is is you had a
goal
and this changes maybe how you want to
do the goal
in your mind and you're kind of
struggling with that a little bit did i
hear that
exactly yeah well it's not wrong to take
the money put it in a mutual fund and go
and play your goal
right okay you're 24 probably in two or
three years you're gonna pay cash for a
house right
that's the goal yeah yeah and so there's
that is not
a bad plan that is an excellent plan i
mean if i'm talking to a 27 year old
with a paid for house and part of the
paid for was mom gave him
25 grand three years ago and he invested
that
i'm calling everybody in this picture
smart absolutely
but if you go ahead and buy today you
you uh uh
you were born and raised in nova scotia
of your career in nova scotia that's
right
okay what do you do for a living uh
digital marketing
good for you okay good money now how
much of a house would you buy 80 let's
say for an example you went and bought
something right now how much would that
house cost you
well i've considered two options here so
an income property which would cost
about
400 maybe even 500 000 versus
uh you know something cheaper in the in
the next
250. yeah i like the neck of 250 if you
were to do that yeah because like 400
takes you above
um but i'm with dave like if you take
that money you park it and you can be 27
years old and go pay cash for it
that's the option i am leaning more
towards uh but
if you do go buy something today i'm
saying you need to you need to stay
north of 250
because honestly you can pay that off
within the next year the income
producing property is a secondary issue
that's that's another step right let's
get you into a house and get it paid off
and then let's talk about income
producing yes
okay so i agree with anthony on that so
here's an idea listen to this
what have you said i'm going to stay
with my plan to pay cash i'm going to
take mom's 25 and we'll put it in a
mutual fund yep
at any point in the next few years even
if you didn't have enough you could
change your mind and put down a big
honking down payment
yep so there's no there's nothing
there's nothing lost
with continuing along your process you
still have the right to change your mind
and every day that you wait to change
your mind you're going to have
more to put down yeah even if you didn't
go all the way to 100 down later
totally yeah so it's not a it's not the
that way the decision is not inc
in concrete i'm going to start with that
absolutely and revisit it
january of every year when i'm setting
my goals for the year yeah
do i want to keep on this plan or do i
want to pull that money out and buy a
house
i'll just work hard dave over the next
two years and then see where i'm at
yeah well every year see how much
progress you got you go man it's right
there i'm gonna go one more year i'm
gonna do this yes
or you might go hey i'm getting married
i'm buying a house
yes you know different things could
change here but this way you don't
you're not locked in and give yourself
permission to revisit the decision every
january yeah
and just get started i like that one the
best because it's not the other one
if you buy the house now you're locked
in you did it yep it's done
yep and you know then you gotta and then
all this other stuff happens so how
often do we meet
24 year olds thinking like this though
dave more and more
because you are out there talking to him
i like you dave
i was hoping you would give me some love
in that area
well i'm telling you but to anthony
o'neil and youtube
yes are the two things that have brought
the 19 year olds to the ramsey stuff
hey man because i'm a serious boomer and
i don't even have dad jokes anymore now
i got grandpa jokes
i'm down to papa dave jokes now it's
really bad
so i gotta have something that connects
um you know
definitely not my focus group anymore
but i love
i'm with you man yeah that and you know
here's the other thing
you and i get to speak to on the radio
in our podcast in live events and book
signing lines
sharp young 23 24 22 19 year olds
all the time all the time and i'll tell
you what that does
it gives me great hope yes in a nation
that where some of you people have lost
your minds
oh man unbelievable but it gives me
great hope
that there are aidens out there in the
world and there's a lot of them a lot of
more than you would think yes good news
we're gonna be okay that was the first
call of the day this is gonna be a great
day
it's gonna be okay this is the dave
ramsey show
[Music]
i'm so tired of people saying don't
pursue your passion because you can't
make any money
i'm like 50 50 with that keep it locked
cuz i got something to say
yo i'm so passionate about this man
because you know today's question is
like yo
um my passion what i really want to do
does not make a lot of money
should i still pursue it let me come off
the top right now and say you know what
yes i want you to still pursue it but i
want you to be wise on how
you pursue it my passion in life was to
become a youth minister now let's be
real a youth minister
does not make a lot of money i was
making maybe 28 000 to maybe 34 000
a year as a full-time youth pastor but
you know what
that's what i was passionate about was i
rich was i making a lot of money
no but i was pursuing my calling and my
calling and your calling
may look different from a doctor's
caller from a lawyer's calling
from an nba star calling or even from a
corporate executive's calling but you
know what
pursue your calling do not allow your
calling to become an excuse
of why you cannot make wise decisions
when it comes to your money so if you
know you want to be a musician for an
example
and musicians do not make that much
money hey
get a side job that can fuel and that
could be
the the vehicle to build your dreams
that's so important i don't want you get
discouraged like oh my gosh i really
want to do this
but it doesn't make a lot of money it's
not going to make me famous
i need to go pursue this no never pursue
something you're not passionate about
my passions led me to where i am today
working with dave ramsey traveling the
country
i was making a little of nothing back
then now i'm blessed
but you know what this is leading me
somewhere else
go after your passions go after what you
want to do but be wise be wise there's
nothing wrong with getting a part-time
job
to help you build what you really want
to do over here
people do that all the time
and while you're not making as much
money make sure you're on a budget
and make sure that you're living below
your means
but yo go pursue your passion go do what
you love to do
because i am and it worked for me and
look at where i am now
i'm inspiring people thank you yo love
you it's your boy anthony o'neil
y'all got me frustrated asking me a
question like this and i'm on this white
drop i'm going off to encourage some
more people
bye around here we're
big believers and high quality real
estate agents
that's why we found the best agents in
your area to work directly with you
these folks actually care about your
financial journey
they hate debt as much as you do and
won't sweet talk you into accepting a
deal you're not comfortable with oh yeah
and there's no extra for you to work
with them you'll get access to the
profiles of trusted agents in your area
you can expect those agents to contact
you directly in less than 24 hours
it doesn't matter if you're buying or
selling or both
we're here to help so if you're ready to
get started
let us help make this experience simple
and rewarding
with the top trusted endorsed local
providers in your area
go to daveramsey.com agents and find
your agent today
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country
or have a better life the army national
guard can help get you there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com to find out more
anthony o'neil is our ramsey personality
is our co-host kind of fall asleep there
with that bump music i was just kind of
i thought i'd take a little nap there
right after lunch open phone's at triple
eight
eight two five five two two five
it's the uh smooth jazz station oh yes
it is that's what it is it is our
producer james is very good yeah he's
he's uh he's grooving in there you guys
seemed a little rowdy i was trying to
calm you down oh
oh he says we were to rowdy okay
there's that anthony it's always you
mike is in orange county hey mike
welcome to the dave ramsey show
good afternoon dave it's a pleasure to
speak to you both you too what's up
um okay so i'm sort of in a semi
malformed baby step
3b uh and i'd love to get your advice at
the start of 2020 i decided to purchase
my very first home
uh i was pretty busy trying really hard
to save up to 20 but i felt like with
interest rates being really low
plus with the southern california real
real estate market appreciation
every year that i was sort of delaying
was putting me further and further
behind
um so i took a 15 000
loan from my 401k in order to help boost
the down payment
but the intention there was to rent out
the extra room to a friend
where the net profit after a year was
going to be 15 000
so i could completely pay off the loan
in a single year um the experiment went
well my friend is interested in staying
for another year so
my question to you is should i take the
cash
now and pay back the 401k loan or
since the 401k loan interest is being
paid back to me
and he's going to stay for another year
should i take the 15 thousand dollars
and put it towards the equity in the
home so that the next time i refinance
or re-amateurize i'm closer if not
beyond twenty percent
and can drop pmi yeah well that would
depend on whether you're going to follow
our plan or yours
right i i've been an
advocate follower of your plan i think
this is the one point that i deviated
and then you're wanting to deviate more
yeah
why would you say more well i would
never tell you to borrow on your 401k to
pay down your home so that you could get
rid of pmi yeah
i i wasn't going to borrow more no
effectively by not paying off the loan
with the money and putting it on the
house it's the same thing
yeah oh i see okay
so pay off the loan yeah pay off to them
okay and then work to pay down your
principal
and then you'll have to get an appraisal
and reset and
get your um get your stuff get your
pmi going that way later and dave i want
to call this out too because i want the
listeners to hear this
we do not that's not how we do things we
do not rob from
from our future and i know this guy said
hey it worked okay
but we hear stories how it didn't work
yeah most of the time it doesn't
exactly and uh i i want america to hear
it's like we don't want you to arrive in
your future
it's kind of like you know if you put
one round in the chamber
and you have five empty rounds and you
point it at your head
and it didn't go off right does that
make it smart
heck no you know it's still freaking
russian roulette
it worked this time you know it's like
yeah
that's great if he chips doesn't mean
i'm gonna pull the trigger again
so uh you know this is the it's that's
kind of a violent bloody idea
but still when i say that i was like man
that's a tough example dude
well i mean the the point is you know
the thing is this
i have done lots of stupid things
that worked and the only downside of
that is is it made me think it worked
yes
an example is uh we were
22 years old or 23 years old and we went
on our very first
cruise right we had never seen anything
like that
that was luxury we're country people
from tennessee we got on that boat and
they were like
you know they were had swordfish and
they had all this stuff and
i mean the place was like a palace yeah
yeah
and my wife bless her heart
what happened walks by this
evil thing called a slot machine
i'm just gonna try this i think this
would be fun
and i said what about losing money is
fun i don't understand how is it fun to
lose money
she drops a quarter in and of course you
know what happened she pulled the
one-armed bandit
the stinking thing goes off like a
christmas tree man
quarters are going everywhere woman won
like three hundred dollars in quarters
you know what that cost me about three
thousand about seven hundred
we didn't have three thousand i was
twenty oh she put the whole 300 back in
over the trip plus another 500 looking
for another 300.
because stupid worked once yes yes
yeah and that's the thing about doing
stupid just because it works once
doesn't mean you sign up for it again
i've done
it i've done it half of my life me too
and i'm just going look there are
just cause you you know you jumped off
the building and you didn't break your
leg
because you landed in some a pile of
leaves right doesn't mean
jumping off of buildings is smart right
but i've done it
right i've done it half my life and i've
just i had to quit
i had to quit i had to go okay there are
principles the law of gravity
is a principle yes borrowing money
borrowing on your 401k is never a good
idea let's
reiterate why you don't borrow on your
401k number one you unplug
a good mutual fund yes you do that would
have been making
10 12 in order to pay yourself back five
or six
and somehow that seems smart i never
figured that out i'm getting the money
you're getting the money the other way
dummy
yep you know and so i don't get it the
other thing is when you leave the
company and you will leave the company
when you die you get fired you get a
better job
yes you will be leaving this company
not if when it's a stable job
yeah pandemic breath right i got that
so yeah when you leave your company you
will that that loan is considered an
early withdrawal and if you do not repay
it in 60 days it is
taxed at your tax rate plus a 10 penalty
you're gonna get hit
in the mouth with a 40 i got you told
you not to do this
penalty so that 10 000 cost you maybe 16
000.
yeah exactly yeah yeah somewhere in
there and so
and you're just asking for trouble yes
now sometimes you can ask for trouble
and trouble doesn't come come on
and man i'll tell you and the reason i'm
so passionate about this is i can look
in the mirror and go
i'm a doofus i have done almost every
one of these things yeah i never had a
401k or i would have borrowed on it
but you know just cause you got just you
know the worst thing happened to me
when i was buying real estate for
nothing down the banks giving me 100
loans because i was buying it fixing it
up the worst thing that happened to me
was
i made really good money and flipped
those houses easily on the first 10
houses yeah
so then i look up at 24 years old
25 years old with three million dollars
in debt
on rental properties doing flips and a
bank gets sold to another bank and calls
our loans
the worst thing that happened to me was
the first ones worked
if i had lost my butt on the first one
the whole
story would not have occurred yes but
instead i'm like sharon
this would be fun and i put the thing in
the slot machine you know
and there you go and ding ding ding ding
ding ding ding let's do this again
robert kiyosaki must be right let's go
deeply in debt with nothing
down you know oh my god i'm going to
sign up for grant cardone i don't think
so
you know no i'm not going to do that i
love robert
i love grant they're both great guys
actually and robert's a friend of mine
but philosophies are awesome but we
don't agree
on those subjects as well i because i
had a different experience and a man
with an experience is not at the mercy
of a man with an opinion and i'm right
there with you
i had the same experience dave not the
same but in the same
area same ideas so this is why we're
picking on you mike because we love you
man
yeah we love you and we love to pick on
you you caught into the dave ramsey show
well i mean that's it so the the thing
is just because you got i mean
what if the roommate had been the
roommate from hell and hadn't paid him
the money
we never gotten this call because he
wouldn't want to extend it
yep wouldn't want to keep doing it he'd
be like oh i violated the principal and
i got caught
and i think well if you put the quarter
in there and call that's a big fun and
it just keeps your quarter
it's not fun and i think for me dave i
just i'm scared to play with my future
i'm depending on that 401k i'm depending
on the roth ira i'm depending on that
to protect my 60 70 80 year old stuff
so i just i don't want to play with it
right now if that means i have to move a
little bit slower into
getting to where i need to get to today
so that my future has a solid future
i am okay with that you know that you're
right there is a
oh i was out at the farm with my
grandson today
and he was a little bitty guy with his
daddy
and we were shooting okay the first time
the little guy shot a gun
yeah i want to teach him to be afraid
of guns yes they're dangerous yes
yes i don't want to teach him to be so
afraid of it that he can't shoot one
yes but i want him to have a healthy
respect
for this explosion that's going off in
your hand that's so good dave
you've got to have a healthy respect and
you got to have a healthy respect for
these principles
yeah because it'll go off man yeah and
and when people don't have respect for
it that's when they get hurt come on
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
we believe the american dream is alive
and available
not for a select few but for everyday
people like us
regardless of background or bloodline we
make our own success
we choose the path to building wealth it
won't happen overnight
we know that investing in the future
takes sacrifice
we won't go it alone we will seek wise
counsel along the way
and refuse to take advice from broke
people we will not make
excuses we will make progress obstacles
will get in our way but we'll go
over them we'll go under them or even
through them
because we have a plan and as we succeed
we will not apologize we are blessed to
be a blessing
to give outrageously change our families
impact our communities and leave a
legacy
we are focused and not finished
i'm john ball this is my beautiful wife
nguyen we live in san antonio texas
and in 2015 i took a 2
683 mile walk across the united states
beginning in san diego california and i
finished my walk
in daytona beach florida
f-16
his buddy's out there somewhere probably
when i got married very young
and after graduating from college i'd
never
been in an airplane never flown an
airplane i'd never even bought a ticket
and ridden on an airplane
and so i went down to the recruiter's
office in our hometown of paris texas
and applied to go to air force pilot
training
was very supportive of that and off we
went to the air force
26 years later i retired as a colonel uh
having been a pilot for most of that
time
uh including a two-year stint as air
force two pilot for vice president gore
and vice president cheney
throughout my air force career i'd
always been an avid exerciser
i'd go out jogging six eight ten miles a
day
uh but towards the end of my career i
was approaching 50 years old my knees
started hurting pretty bad
i went to the doctor the doctor said you
really need to lay off the running for a
while so i started walking
very the very next day i started walking
for exercise
and i never stopped walking
[Music]
so i was just honestly out walking one
day
and it just crossed my mind i wonder
what it would be like to walk
a long distance specifically i
immediately came to my mind what would
it be like to walk all the way across
the country
after i retired from the air force i
went to work here in san antonio
with a government contractor and at that
point wen and i were
able to live off of my air force pension
but we wanted to build our retirement
home here in san antonio
with the exception of the savings that
we did
we put everything else towards paying
off our retirement home
[Music]
after i retired i immediately started
on this walk
the walk ended up being 2 686 miles in
170 days
from march 1st to august 17th
well there are a couple a couple of
things that i had to consider
number one i had to be in good enough
health to be able to walk that kind of
distance uh it's pretty grueling walking
170 days without a lot of rest
the other thing is economically i had to
be able to do that and that all tied
into
being debt free we cash flowed the
entire trip
and the purpose of the trip was to
create an endowed scholarship at my alma
mater texas a
m and because i had prepared financially
to be able to go
on the walk at my own cost all the
donations that came in
went straight to the scholarship
there's a tradition at texas a m about
the aggie ring
we've had the same graduation ring for
over a hundred years
and so really it's a it's your tradition
and it's a it's an
honor that all aggies have that to wear
their aggie ring
but not everybody can afford their aggie
ring when it's
time for them to uh to get it 350
very generous people gave over 27 000
to establish the walking aggie and
doubtering scholarship
so that each year one male student or
two female students receive their aggie
ring
as a result of the scholarship and my
completion of the
coast-to-coast walk of the things that
makes the dave ramsey show unique from
other shows
is that we genuinely care about our
listeners
that's why we are very intentional about
choosing
our advertisers blinds.com
offers high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and then their customer service is truly
unbeatable
they make it simple to shop for blinds
shades and interior shutters from home
with easy online ordering and
free shipping right to your door and
blinds.com will help you
every step of the way just like they've
helped
thousands of my listeners with free
design help
by phone and online plus they guarantee
the perfect fit
go today and take advantage of this
week's
special offer
anthony o'neil ramsey personality is my
co-host today here on the air open
phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
triple eight
eight two five five two two five
alejandro and brenda are with us in
pensacola florida to do a debt-free
scream
and i assume you are there serving
uh yes sir uh we are in the air force
i'm in the air force
house i suspected with it being
pensacola thank you for your service
how much data have you guys paid off so
we paid off 369
000 with 735 dollars did you say
369 000 yes sir 369
735 dollars wow goodness all right
how long did this take five years nine
months
ah okay that makes a little more sense
and what's your household income range
during that five years and nine months
well we started out at 108 000
and finished up at 152 000.
wow good for you now you're in the
military is your wife work outside the
home
yes i'm in the air force and i work for
an insurance company
great very cool okay i'm gonna guess and
say with this huge amount of money
that that includes paying off your house
yes
touchdown
wow talking to weird people how old are
you two
32 we're both 32. are you kidding me wow
that so rocks i'm so proud of y'all oh
yeah
thank you freaking amazing oh yeah okay
in a long time but you know it
we did it well in the scope of life five
years nine months isn't spit you have a
paid for house
i mean you're impressive so tell me how
did all this start
five years and nine months ago
oh i went i walked into the lunchroom at
work
and i heard a group of girls talking
about you and i was like
man i'm going to look him up i want to
know what he's all about and then
i did that while working and then i went
home to my husband i was like
hey i have an idea and then i just told
him he looked it up and he's like
all right let's do it i'm going to jump
on board with you wow
just like that yeah i mean of course i
was a little bit skeptical so i just
looked it up and
you know everything sounded really well
the total money makeover was great and
and we just we got going right away we
just
he here's the thing dave uh we don't
want to end up
you know god bless our parents but
they're both in their 60s 70s
living paycheck to paycheck and they
still have a mortgage
we just want to change our our family
tree uh we just want to be weird you
know
we we want to change our family tree and
and to us this is a true
definition of the american dream you
know
okay i'm looking at your name i'm
hearing a little bit of an accent what
is your heritage
yeah yeah so i was born in colombia and
my wife was
uh born in miami uh her parents are from
argentina
okay okay cool that's exciting
well when so when you say the american
dream it means something absolutely
that's pretty impressive and you're here
you are serving in the air force this is
this is very cool
very cool yes sir so what do you do in
the air force
uh i i'm a pilot what do you fly
i fly uh special operations airplane
right there that's awesome man well
thank you thank you thank you thank you
then
alejandro and brenda have a question so
you all started this journey at 27 years
old
um i'm curious what were your other
peers thinking about you all
in your 20s you all are saying yo we
want to attack this debt we want to pay
off our mortgage
what were your peers on board were they
looking at you like you're crazy you're
young enjoy your life
what was that atmosphere for you all
yeah of course so you have a little bit
of both situations going you know some
of them are very skeptical some of them
are like oh yeah go for it but
i think i think most of them they don't
really see it until you're actually
uh you know going through it and
especially right now yeah you're gonna
pay for house
yeah so right now we have quite a few
friends that are on board but you know
going through the process not everybody
catches up you know they don't catch on
that hey this is
this is possible yeah well that's
amazing dude
very very well done i'm so proud of you
guys
who are your biggest cheerleaders i
i would say uh my friend jason i have uh
john and george
uh both uh but all three of them
great friends and i would say
they kept us motivated um and so i'm
pretty sure
we're being motivational to them as well
so yeah yeah so how about your
your parents and so forth where they
after they see what you guys have done
did it inspire them to do anything
well it's kind of helped them a little
but
for them it's harder because they don't
see it they don't see that this is
possible for them because they're
already like
older both of our fathers are retired
our moms are the only ones working
so we're trying to make them get on a
straight budget and stuff
but it's been a little bit hard sure but
then i feel like our
siblings are also like realizing that
this is
worth a try and you know i feel like
they're almost on board not a hundred
percent but i
like i tell them almost doesn't count oh
it's gracious wow yeah they i think they
say that in special ops don't they
alejandra
that's right yeah almost is not going to
work
yeah so you guys you guys have a paid
for home you're 100
debt free i i got to ask what's next for
this young couple
oh i i was going to tell dave and you
anthony
we're going to be calling back in a few
years for the millionaire theme hour
come on
make sure i'm not on the show let's
bring chris hogan on that show so
you guys are heroes well if it's a
millionaire theme hour it'll be on a day
chris's own probably
since that's kind of his stuff yeah man
way to go you guys well we're going to
send you a copy of chris's book
everyday millionaires because that is
the next chapter for sure in your story
you guys are rock stars you are absolute
heroes we're so proud of you and again
thank you for your service
alejandro and brenda 369
000 paid off in five years and nine
months making 108 152
that includes a paid for home at 32
years old
shut up count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
three two one right there
yeah that is awesome
man oh man oh man thank you lord
good stuff yeah very well done mark as
well as mark is
in dallas texas hey mark how can we help
hey dave hey anthony so um
i'm uh currently working full time but
by the end of the year i'm more than
likely gonna be leaving my full-time
status
and with that um my full-time health
benefits
now i already know that i can go on to
my wife
insurance um that will cost us an extra
per month give or take um i was just
wondering
if you think i should do that look into
um the open
insurance market or look at a different
uh option
well that's really your two options is
go to daveramsey.com and click on elp
for health insurance talk to one of the
brokers and have them shop around and
get you the best deal as an
individual policy and compare that to
what it will cost additionally and
compare the coverages
for if you were added to your wife's
policy i will give you a guess
but i would do the research because if
all the facts are in front of you and
all the options are in front of you
the answer will bark at you yeah right
yeah
you go pick me pick me right and so uh
that's what you're talking about that's
what happens if you gather up good
amounts of information when you're
making any major decisions so i mean if
you had
if you had an option that's 900 and an
option that's 700 and hers is 600 and
hers has more coverage
it's kind of like a no duh right yep
right and so that's what's going to
happen
something like that is going to land on
your play i'm going to guess
i'm still gonna do the exercise but i'm
gonna guess if i'm in your shoes
that adding to her policy is probably
gonna be your most coverage for the
least money
yeah all right that's it
but go the elp and shop it to be sure i
could be wrong have you ever seen
something otherwise dave to where
yeah it has okay 600 is a lot it is to
add to your spouse's policy i was just
buying and if he's 24 we didn't ask his
agent he's got zero health problems he's
not overweight
um you know obesity is huge on health
insurance
and uh not smoking yes right not jumping
out of perfectly good airplanes that
kind of stuff
right then uh all that kind of stuff
then you know he could get a policy for
400 bucks
you know with maybe a 5 000 deductible
hsa plan or something it's possible
depending on the state depending on
what's going on but you know we don't
know his health
statistics to run a number right here so
just run it with the
elps they'll shop around they'll help
you get the best deal
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
some of the biggest aha moments i've had
in life is when i've realized and
learned more
about who i am and why i am the way i am
when i have more self-awareness i
realize wow i win more
in my marriage with my kids at work and
other relationships in life
and so as i was on that journey i
started to realize wow what if i took
some of that self-awareness and applied
it to my money
understanding not just how to handle my
money but
why i handle money the way i do so in my
new book
know yourself know your money we're
going to go underneath the foundation of
all the money principles i've been
talking about for over a decade
so besides just budgeting and getting
out of debt and saving and retirement
and
insurance all these principles we talk
about when we go underneath the
foundation and start
talking about not just how you handle
money but why you handle money the way
you do
i promise that self-awareness will help
you win with money
faster and this book is going to give
you the fuel
and the hope to cause it to happen
[Music]
[Applause]
hey guys george campbell here today's
minute money hack is a tasty one my
every dollar budgeting app says i only
have a few bucks left to spend for lunch
so i'm headed to one of my favorite
spots
chipotle let's go alright so i've placed
my order ahead of time using the app
avoid the burrito and get the bowl i'll
explain later
now little known fact you get up to
three customizations on your meal which
means extra stuff
here's some options go half and half
with your meat beans
and rice which usually means extra food
and get a tortilla on the side to make
your own
massive burrito
let's pick this thing up and see how we
did
here's your average burrito weighing in
at 24 ounces but when you order a
maximized bowl with a tortilla on the
side it weighs in at a massive 34 ounces
for the same exact price
on a tighter budget order two tacos and
follow the same steps for under five
bucks
on an even tighter shoestring budget
order a single taco loaded up for two
dollars and forty cents
and there's your minute money hack
if you're financially conscious you know
that healthcare expenses can take a big
bite out of your budget
christian healthcare ministries or chm
is here to help
trim those expenses and make sure your
family is cared for
chm is not health insurance but it is
christians helping other christians by
sharing each other's medical bills
most people have the means to pay for
basic doctor services but
when it comes to something on a much
larger scale say
several thousand dollars for surgery or
hospitalization
folks are worried they'll be left to try
and find a way to pay for that
themselves
not too long ago i was diagnosed with
ovarian cancer
and they really came through so far
we've had over 180
000 worth of bills and got close to 75
in discounts chm shared the rest of the
expenses
to see if chm is right for you and your
budget
check out ch chministries.org
backslash budget
[Music]
anthony o'neill ramsey personality is my
co-host today here on the air
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five
five two two five jesse is with us in
oklahoma city hi jesse how are you
i'm doing good how about you better than
i deserve what's up
so uh my wife and i were both
veterans i'm 25 and she's
27. we work for the government now
um and our net pay after taxes and
everything
is about twelve thousand a month and
then forty four hundred of it
uh is guaranteed for the rest of our
lives
and i just i mean i'm just not sure
like should i pay um
the house off and then stay here or is
it okay for me to want to buy
a bigger house once this one that's paid
off i just don't know what to do
if i should pay the stuff and then
invest or well well done to start with
you're making really good money
you're in good shape what's your house
worth
it's 200 000
in okc that's a pretty good house yeah
yeah it's not bad yeah okay and there's
nothing
is there anything wrong with wanting to
move up absolutely not so what do you
want to do
what do you want to do i mean i would
really like
a bigger house we don't have any kids or
anything but you know we kind of imagine
our place being the one where everyone
comes to and
you know celebrates the holidays or
whatever so that
i mean that's kind of like our dream is
to get a big house but
jesse when you say a big house how much
is that what are you talking about
maybe like 800 or 900 for the next one
that's a huge jump yeah i guess uh
it is i don't know if i would
i don't know if i would go from a 200 to
a 900 000
house right now not saying you can never
get there i'm talking about i would
maybe go from a 200 to maybe a four or
five hundred uh max hunters uh
but i'm not saying equipment from our
own day but i'm not saying you can't
never get there i'm just saying baby
stepping your way up there
because i'm pretty sure you're 24. if
you're making 12 000 now
uh you your income should be going up
and so as your income goes up then you
can even go up a little bit more into
housing
but right now if you're looking to move
up i would say move up get you a bigger
house but
that's like going from a 2 000 square
feet
to a 8 000 square feet when you're
talking about 900 000
in oklahoma yeah yes sir again
to reiterate you've done a really really
good job the fact that you're asking the
question makes you in the smart column
so that's all really good we teach a
thing called the baby steps
you probably have heard it where you
have an emergency fund in place and
you're out of debt before we have any of
these discussions are you there
we're not there yet i kind of have a
four year plan
between now and that next house if we do
buy it
because i wanted to save up at least you
know 30
of whatever the next house is so that
was kind of the other part to my
question is should i
well first the first thing you need to
do is get out of debt except the house
yeah before we even have a discussion
the second thing is you make sure you
have an emergency fund of three to six
months of expenses right
then you start putting 15 of your income
into retirement
then you start saying i'm going to build
some additional side wealth to have a
bigger down payment on a house to go
with the house i've got here
when you purchase that which is like six
years from now probably
if you do all of those things yeah um
then then when you purchase that it
needs to be where the payment is no more
than a fourth of your take-home pay
on a 15-year fixed as long as you're in
that range i'm okay
the thing you need to keep in the back
of your head that you really need to be
working for
is not just a bigger house but a paid
for house because
all the data we have on millionaires
there are two main components to their
wealth
when they hit the first one to five
million dollars in net worth
component number one is a paid for house
and on average they do it
in 10 to 11 years yeah someone's one
group we study was 11.2 the ramsey group
that we studied did it in 10.2 they did
a little bit faster
but still right in that range you get
the house paid off and then you pile
money in the 401k the 403b
the roth iras and that's the other
segment that causes you to become
wealthy
if you continually are reaching too far
past
and you stay house poor yes you limit
your ability to ever get the house paid
off
and you limit your ability to put money
in the 401k so you're going to stunt
your growth
yeah towards becoming a millionaire that
so that's what you want to gauge and
keeping a healthy tension there
but the answer is yes you can get a
bigger house let's just do it gradually
and do it
in the right order so then at the right
timing so you don't stunt your own
growth
absolutely and then also too i want to
challenge you jesse as well to
step back and look if you're making
twelve thousand dollars net
i think you can get out of debt actually
before four years i don't know how much
yeah depending on how much debt you have
but you know with that kind of income
sounded like you're a smart man i'm
pretty sure i would think you're not
extremely up there
so attack that with a solid plan so that
we can get it
get into your house maybe within the
next three to four years
not just four absolutely and we're going
to help you with this i want you to go
through ramsey plus i'm going to give
you a one-year
membership to ramsey plus just to say on
veterans today to say thank you for
serving
yeah and so i want you to go through
that that includes everything you need
to know about money
financial peace university it puts you
into the every dollar premium app it
puts you into the baby steps tracker app
it puts you into the groups where you've
got the support it gives you access to
coaches and counselors to get your
questions answered
and it's all digital and those of you
want to buy something for christmas for
somebody
this is an easy way to do it there's no
shipping needed right
and so ramsay plus the all-access
membership it is the best thing we do
around here
it is and i'm going to give it to you as
a gift just to say thank you for serving
so hold on kelly i'll pick up
and with the rest of you uh if you want
to do a free trial or you want to buy it
as a christmas gift
go to daveramsey.com store
or slash fpu either one and you can get
signed up for
either a free trial or it'll help you
purchase the gift
for a family member a friend for a
year's worth of ramsay plus the premium
version of every dollar
financial peace university legacy
journey a bunch of rachel's content
bunch of hogan's content all kinds of
stuff in there available to you oh and
while you're at daveramsey.com the rest
of you you need to remember we're giving
away 500
a week between now and christmas sign up
for the free giveaway and there is no
purchase necessary to do that
kevin's in great falls virginia hi kevin
welcome to the dave ramsey show
thank you dave and anthony for taking my
call um
just to give you a little background
i'll be 62 at the end of the month
my wife is 60. happy birthday happy
early birthday
i'm sorry can you hear me now yes happy
oh thank you thank you um i'll be
moving to a new job soon um where i'll
be getting another 21k
increase and trying to decide whether or
not to bump up the
retirement account or to pay down the
mortgage
how much is the mortgage and how much is
in retirement
i have about 880 in retirement
the mortgage is 282. oh yeah bump up the
mortgage yep
no questions you're already a
millionaire yep
get the mortgage knocked down okay
so uh just just press on with that then
i guess
i mean you i always put 15 of your
income regardless of what it is in the
retirement and every other
dollar you can find in your budget
finish that mortgage
here's the thing you have done an
incredible job
i mean your your net worth is very
likely with the equity in your home over
a million dollars yes you got 880 alone
in your 401k yeah
okay so all i got to do scratch up 120
somewhere to get you there so you're
you're there
all right and the the thing
that you because you're such a saver and
you're
you've been so wise and so diligent over
a long period of time otherwise you
wouldn't have this freaking money
right okay so i know this about you but
the thing that you don't realize is
what's going to happen when you pay off
that mortgage
there's going to be like this snap
inside your heart
you're almost going to hear it audibly
yeah and you're going to go
dad come i can breathe i can breathe i'm
free
yes yes you know and that's you're only
288 thousand away from that and
i can smell a 200 000 income in this
story so
uh especially with the 21 000 increase
so just lean in on that baby put 15
in there let's knock that mortgage out
as soon as possible
and you're gonna you mark my words
you're gonna say ramsay was right
you're gonna have a physical spiritual
emotional experience when you pay that
mortgage off yeah it's gonna blow your
freaking mind
this is the dave ramsey
[Music]
people call my show all the time
complaining
about how awful their timeshares are
and yet you guys have been really having
good success getting people
out of their time shares we have we kind
of helped create this industry
now there's a lot of exit companies out
there they come and they go
timeshare extra team is different i mean
we we now have
you know almost 20 000 people out of
timeshare contracts actual results
actual results big deal our guarantee is
that if we can't get you out of your
timeshare
we give you your money back hey if you
need out
timeshare exit team is the team
the only team that i trust to help you
schedule your free consultation by
calling 844
999 exit or
timeshareexitteam.com we
first contacted troy through the elp
program we knew that
he was already vetted that he was
someone that was trustworthy by
the eop program standards and troy
really eased a lot of those concerns and
fears
[Music]
i got more than my share of input from
people telling me that it was dangerous
that there were a lot of mean people out
there
and that it was just generally a bad
idea to to go walking on my own without
any help or support
for six months uh i will tell you that
that is the one
thing that i learned throughout this
walk was
how kind people are in six months i
never had
one single incident where i felt
threatened in any way
by anyone i walked into gas stations i
walked into cafes i was greeted on the
shoulder of the road with people
offering me rides and water and food
the the best experience out of the whole
trip
was just how kind of people were to me
there was a relief because as a family
we were very worried about his safety
and
he just had a great experience
[Music]
i had a very detailed plan for the walk
i knew where i was supposed to be every
day
with that in mind we booked a disney
cruise that left
the afternoon of august the 17th
so i knew before i ever started on march
1st in san diego that i had to be
in daytona beach florida on august 17th
or that cruise ship was going to leave
without us the whole family flew out to
san diego to see him off and uh
it was really kind of sad because we
were all together and about to go to
disneyland and here he was all by
himself going to walk away but anyway
we could talk every day just very seldom
did we not speak
every day so we kind of kept up with him
and knew that he was okay
and it just all worked out good and then
we all went including my mom on the
other end
and took a disney cruise so he better
finish on time
we were debt-free we were millionaires
by then
and that just that just freed us up to
be able to really
go out and live life the way uh we had
planned
for a long time you know we go to europe
and tool around europe with our
backpacks for
weeks at a time we have a goaling
motorcycle with a little trailer we pull
right behind it we
just got back from a trip to canada and
then in april we're going
to visit eastern europe so we really
like to travel and being debt free has
enabled us to do that
and that was something we always hoped
we could do and now we're living it
being debt-free before i started this
walk it really enabled me to be able to
pull this off we saved our entire air
force career and we saved and
were able to pay off our house and
become debt free the month
that i've started on the walk and it
really it really just
lived out the philosophy that if you
live like no one else
you can live and give like no one else
[Music]
right now 78 of americans
are living paycheck to paycheck that
means if you look around your own
neighborhood
eight out of 10 families on your street
cannot cover a basic emergency
they might not be able to afford their
mortgage payment
they're not keeping their own money
they're sending
a fourth of their paycheck to car
payments student loans and the credit
card companies
and the worst part most of these folks
don't even know why they're stressed
why they're fighting with their spouse
while there's too much month
left at the end of the money it's not
okay
they shouldn't have to live that way
what if you could help them win with
money
you can as a financial peace university
coordinator
our coordinators have helped over 5
million people
learn how to pay off debt spend and save
wisely and ultimately
change their lives if you have a heart
for helping people
then you're the perfect person to become
a coordinator
and you don't need a lot of time or any
special training plus someone from my
team will walk alongside you and
guide you through the entire process
join
us in changing lives and take the first
step
to becoming a financial peace university
coordinator
[Music]
today
getting your money in order can feel a
little overwhelming
that's why dave created the baby steps
they break it down for you and show you
exactly what to do next
baby step 2 is where you get rid of all
of your debts one at a time using the
debt snowball
in the debt snowball you list your debts
smallest to largest by amount owed
pay minimum payments on all of the debts
except for the smallest one
and attack it with a vengeance i mean go
ninja crazy on it once it's gone take
the money you were putting towards that
debt
plus any extra money you can find and
attack the next debt on the list
once it's gone take that combined
payment and go on to the next step
knock them out one by one the point of
the debt snowball is behavior
modification
when you ditch the small debt first you
see progress that will get you fired up
soon the second debt will follow and
then the next when you see that the plan
is working
you'll stick to it by sticking to it
you'll eventually succeed in becoming
depth the total debt is around 640
thousand dollars
[Music]
i just don't even know where to begin
and i don't know what to do i'm not
scared
welcome to the dave ramsey show you are
not a victim
you are the hero in your story you can
be intentional about your character
you can have money and a career
everything just started making sense i
was like i'm gonna
do this live from the headquarters of
ramsey solutions broadcasting from the
dollar cart rental studios it's the dave
ramsey show where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i am dave
ramsey your host anthony o'neil ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author of the book debt-free degree is
my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five as we talk about
your life and your money triple eight
eight two five five two two
five brandon is with us in denver to
start off this hour hey brandon how are
you
i'm wonderful sir how are you today
better than i deserve how can we help
perfect i am a one-third
owner of an llc that owns uh three
rental properties within it the llc is
owned
one by myself one-third by my brother
one third by my parents we all kind of
got into business together about seven
years ago
we would like to dissolve the llc
because we're all kind of a different
point for our life and would like to be
able to go do different things
everything's good relationally and we're
trying to figure out the best way to do
that without
a really dramatic capital gains tax hit
or if there's any way to
to do that can you we
all purchased into the llc for about two
hundred and ten thousand each and bought
rental property uh there was about six
hundred thirty thousand dollars in value
it's now grown to about a million 95
which would mean
each of our current stake in the llc is
about 365.
we want to know can we divvy up the llc
based on
the property values of when we bought
them so that we can
then each pay the capital gains tax
later if we ever were to sell the
properties
or do we have to do that now as of
current market value
you're gonna have to get with a a tax
professional i probably would go so far
as to recommend a
a tax attorney to help you walk through
this
so your game plan do all three
properties have similar equities and so
you're just going to each take a
property
unfortunately no one one
is uh two of them are very similar
they're both four plex units that are
currently very very similar one is a
single town home
the two four plexes are probably worth
about 420 to 450 000 each
not counting not counting the capital
gains
does anyone necessarily want to really
have a huge desire to keep any of these
properties
we all would love to keep the property
because the real estate end is something
all three of us would like to do
long term we're just looking to dissolve
the partnership
um to keep good relationships and to
make sure that we don't ever run into an
area where
we're trying to okay so if they're
unequal one of you is going to give
another one some money and the property
which which would work actually the best
the way that is my
my brother would like to take the
smaller of the properties
and then um be able for us to to pay him
for the difference of what the value
would be and so what
what which is no problem we we have my
wife and i have
the money to do that uh my parents have
the money to do that we would have no
problem i'll tell you how i think you
can do it but you're gonna have to go to
somebody
that's uh about two notches smarter than
me
to be sure okay there's a thing called a
1031 tax deferred exchange
and that is how we used to trade
properties in the old days you'd you
know you'd pick out a property
that you wanted i had a property and we
would trade the properties and the
capital gains
swa are the gains moved one property to
the other
and there was no activation of the gain
no taxes okay yes sir
now they've advanced that uh okay
to where you can sell a property into
a special escrow account for a 1031
tax deferred exchange and then you have
a certain number of days i believe it's
like 60 days or something like that
to select the next property and roll
your equity
into that and uh when you do
it is is considered a trade and so there
is no taxes
the capital gains that your basis moves
from your old property into the new
property
so eventually someday somebody's going
to get the tax hit but
for now you've moved your equity and
your taxable gains over into the other
property so what i'm thinking here is
that you guys might be able to flip this
whole thing
into that escrow account and use that
escrow account to parse out
each of you getting one of the three in
other words
you guys sell it uh into the escrow
account
and then each of you buy the property
that you want out of that escrow account
under a 1031 tax deferred exchange
umbrella that
might work that that was our hope
initially we actually have been to
at least one accountant so far that's
told us that's not an option
because since the properties are owned
by the llc
the llc would have to then yeah buy the
properties that you can't
that you wouldn't be able to transfer
them to individual ownership yeah that's
true
that's right okay so much for my theory
yeah i think i think i think you got
better advice from him than you did me
okay crap i just try to keep from giving
the government money
you and me both brother you and me both
uh
oh let me thank you let me tell you i
think i think the other thing you can do
is that um you guys are gonna have to
trade some money with each other
but if one of you kept the all the
shares in the llc
that one is going to have no gain right
the other two are going to have gains
when you move it out and the one that
keeps the shares in the llc
doesn't have any gains going to have to
morally want to have to help pay the
taxes to the
the other two create when you move them
out which is which is absolutely an
option that we looked at kind of just
making sure
with with that both morally and legally
if we were to do that
and then that person who is not taking
the capital gains hit
would it be both moral and legal to
exchange funds
you know to the people that are taking
the capital gains hit under the gift
under the gift tax law or with that
person
okay you could do it under gift tax law
and if it's in excess of the
uh the the this this next year's gift
tax limit which i don't remember what it
is probably 14
000 or so it's indexed it changes every
year and if and if it's in excess of
that
unless you guys have estates over 20
million dollars each
you can do a unified estate tax credit
and avoid the
gift tax and you can move any amount
oh i didn't think about going that route
okay yeah we the my parents would
be over the 20 000 but they would
probably be the one that would keep the
share of the llc's
20 million if we did or 20 million
excuse me yeah they they have a
net worth over that but they would
probably get their way okay there
there's a way to do that
and um you know i
this is a great this is a great riddle i
love it it's a wonderful riddle
to work through it because but there's
there is a way to do it and screw the
government
i promise you there is and i'm gonna
find it i'm going to miss it i'm going
to keep on this
because there's a way to do it that is
legal and moral
under the current tax law you've just
got to think it through and uh so far
two of the ideas didn't work but uh
uh yeah you can you can move some money
around i can give anybody money
i just if i give them more than the gift
tax indexed amount which
i can't remember what that is this year
but um
i've got a cheat sheet here somewhere uh
i can't even find that oh well uh oh
well
oh no it's 15 000 15 000 right now and
it's going to go up
so okay so you can move 15 000 but your
your capital gains is going to be more
than 15k on these things because you're
you've gone from you've doubled you've
gone six hundred thousand and two
hundred thousand each
uh three hundred two hundred yeah
well your capital gains probably gonna
be 30 grand a piece on these things
it's not bad uh depending on if you if
you depreciated them down pretty heavy
maybe it might be more than that
it might be 40 000 but um you can get
pretty close to on the 15. you could do
15 one year 15 another year and not even
get in the unified estate tax credit
maybe
there's a way to do this it's just a
barrel of fish hooks that you're gonna
like when my ski rope gets tangled up
sit and take an hour and untangle it but
you know that's what you got here fun
this is the dave ramsey show
i've been avoiding this question for a
while because i don't want to force my
opinion on you
today's question is what's my thoughts
on gambling keep it locked i'll see you
right after this intro
[Music]
i don't think there's nothing wrong and
you're not crazy if you're gambling
i look at gambling by drinking as long
as you're doing it and you are
okay with it personally yourself and
you're not taking it too
far i don't i don't think there's a
problem with it
from myself i have never gambled
and i do not have a desire to just walk
into a gas station
spend money to get a lotto ticket that
more than likely
i'm not going to win anything i've gone
to las vegas
and i've stepped inside a casino and
i've never
put even a quarter in the machine
because i like
my quarters i have friends who will go
and spend maybe a hundred dollars and
have some fun
and there's nothing wrong with that
here's my thing
priorities if you're out there gambling
and you're still behind on bills
or you're still in debt but then you
want to give a hundred dollars
in hope that you'll win a lot to me it
just shows me that your priorities are
not in place
and as a single man that's debt-free you
know what my priority is
is building my money and investing my
money so that way i can take my family
and my kids across the world i think a
stat said that right now there's nearly
four
million individuals with a gambling
problem to me
that's scary but again
so you you know i'm a christian man
are you sinning because you're gambling
no are you sinning because you may have
one drink and you're not getting drunk
no you got to go by your personal
convictions
you got to go by how you feel for
anthony o'neil
i just don't gamble i like my money
and i don't want to throw it in the
trash
line i got nothing to say
connor cut off the camera running on
inside
see y'all on this video bye
step one one thousand dollars to start
your emergency fund
step two pay off all debt using the debt
snowball
step three three to six months of
expenses
in savings step four invest fifteen
percent of household income
in roth iras and pre-tax retirement
step five college funding for children
step six pay off house early
step 7 build wealth and give
drawn to christian healthcare ministries
because we both had young families and
we wanted to have more children
and we had also just started a real
estate company and needed to find health
care coverage that would meet our needs
chm is not health insurance but it is
christians helping other christians by
sharing each other's medical bills
the medical bill sharing from chm was
exactly the way the website described it
there were no surprises no bait and
switch no hidden agenda
chm did everything they said they would
by sharing all of our eligible needs
we like that it's a non-profit ministry
and that we were being better stewards
of our money
all while helping other families
established in 1981
and accredited by the better business
bureau chm is here to meet the needs of
your growing family or small business
get started today and check us out at
chministries.org
backslash budget that's chministries.org
backslash budget we absolutely believe
in it
[Music]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality
is my co-host today open phones a triple
eight eight two five
five two two five alina is with us in
cleveland ohio hi elena how are you
hi dave i'm good how are you better than
i deserve what's up
so i just had a quick question i'm
making my debt snowball
and i'm currently
i have a list right now for everything
besides student loans and collections
now i'm currently still in school do i
pay off the student loans or do i go
towards the collection
with the student loans and deferment
right now
how much longer do you have in school
elena
um if i continue two more years
if i stop and finish every pay
everything off would be
i would take a break for a year okay are
you cash flowing to what the rest of
your college experience right now
no that's why i was planning on stopping
to
bring it back to cash flow okay all
right
so there's a difference in paying
everything off while you're taking time
off to pay everything off
or taking time off because you can't
cash flow it yeah
which is it um i'm taking time off
because i can't cash flow and don't want
to get more
interested in that okay okay okay and
during that time you're going to pile up
money to go back to school
first or you're going to get out of debt
first
um it would be paying off my debt and
then
start uh saving for school gotcha
okay because if you quit school you're
gonna activate these student loans
right right
all right how much debt do you have
total again
total is about 28. how old are you
23. what are you studying yeah
finances and how much of the 28 is
student loan
only 11. and what is in how much is in
collections
about seven okay what's that from
uh credit cards and
what they're called cash advance loans
and how long has it been since you've
paid on those that are in collections
um majority of them are like a little
over a year
okay okay and what is the other ten
thousand dollars
um personal loans
uh my lease my
uh credit card that's active at the
moment and
what else is it okay your lease yeah
yes what do you mean your lease
um the lease payment what do you like
at least a car okay what do you owe on
your car what's it take to pay the car
off
about a little less than four thousand
just about four
so you're almost at the end of it yes
are you working right now i am how many
are you making yeah yearly is about 34.
okay what do you do what do you do
at least only now i am in training to be
an accountant
okay okay so the student loans you're
not paying anything on those
collections you're not hardly paying
anything on it
so it's almost as if you're out of debt
now
in terms of what your monthly exposure
is so why can't you cash flow school
if you don't pay on the student loans
and you don't pay on collections right
now
because that's the majority of your debt
can you think of that how much how much
how much does it cost you to go to
school a semester
about it's been about three thousand
give or take okay yeah 3k so you're
looking at
i mean well actually you still can do
that you still can do that
what's your monthly payment on this
lease
and it's going to be over in just a few
months right correct
now what are you going to do at the end
of that for a car
um i actually have a car but i
did a stupid decision and went for the
lease but i'm going to go back to my
regular car there we go and it's paid
for
and it's paid for yes okay yeah so we
get the call we get the lease paid off
we leave the collections in collections
don't understand you don't pay on the
student loans
and you cash flow college and here's the
other thing and you don't have to quit
yeah and uh you cut up these credit
cards because you're just digging
yourself into a deeper hole
that's a good catch all right so because
we're talking about these credit cards
you say you still have currently open
so you need to stop borrowing money
right now
oh yeah i'm that one getting paid off
next month actually and it's getting
closed out
is it is it cut up yes
you sure you should you just said it was
active you could be honest with me
it's open as active but it's not i don't
swipe it i can't slice it
up you did cut the card in half
literally
i sure did okay i'm proud of you yeah
there you go yeah all right that's a
good sign
all right here's what i want you to do i
want you to get in ramsey plus yes sir
we're going to pay for it for you and
that includes financial peace university
the every dollar premium app everything
you need to get through this kiddo
there's no reason for you to quit school
i want you to keep going yeah
but you're going to take an extra job
and you're going to have about one more
year
you're going to be real tired this year
yeah because you're going to work all
the time and go to school all the time
but here's what's going to happen at the
end of that year you're going to have no
current credit card debt you're going to
have no card debt
and you're going to have gotten rid of
the personal loans so the only debt that
you have you're not making payments on
and then you'll be able to cash flow
school originally does that make sense
it does and i think you can stay in
school and do every bit of this but
you're going to be working a lot
yeah that's six thousand dollars a year
you can do that alina
and honestly maybe even consider looking
at uber
and since you're online and you already
have two years into it uh maybe
even consider going online doing some
tutoring so you can make up your own
hours so it doesn't get in the way of
your education process
but you can get to six thousand dollars
just from doing a side gig
yeah you can deliver pizzas and get that
yeah and so knock this stuff out get
that car gone
get that the credit card the active
credit card's gone leave the stuff
that's in collections in collections the
student loans
are still stagnant while you're in
school so you're not having a cash flow
there then all we got to come up with is
three grand a semester and you can get
that yeah
and so it but you're gonna have to be on
a real detailed plan and it's like an
obsession for you
yeah that i'm going to school with
adding no more debt and then when you
come out of school
you can address that remaining 18 000
very very quickly and you will know how
to do it because i'm going to teach you
how
anthony's going to teach you how in
financial peace university
with ramsey plus so i'm going to give
you a one year membership
and you go through every detail of that
and you do everything i say to do
and if you do that you're going to come
out and be going touchdown
yes you're going to be going i freaking
want and don't go make up your own plan
ours works yeah all right so hold on
kelly i'll pick up and we're gonna get
you signed up as a gift
and uh i don't want you to quit school i
want you to finish yeah
i'm proud of you you're you're you're a
neat young lady cool and some people are
probably asking himself well how come
dave didn't tell her to stop and
pay off her debt because she's already
halfway there that's three grand yes
yeah she's not going to an expensive
school no if she told me she was gonna
spend fifty thousand dollars a year
she's quitting right because there's no
way she's cash flowing that
right this is within reach yes and the
student loans can sit there
that's what they're designed to do for a
student absolutely
and the collections they can sit there
too absolutely the longer they sit there
the more
pliable they'll get
only only only only on the dave rapture
show but at the same time though six
thousand dollars a year that's
less than an average way less you know
that's average is ten thousand dollars a
year
yeah so she's in a good position to go
in ahead and cash flow
that then her oh yeah kelly give her
give her his
debt-free degree book too absolutely to
go with the ramsey plus package oh my
gosh i definitely need that
yeah yeah you think about giving away
your book absolutely what's wrong with
you go ahead and give her destroy your
student loan debt so she can already
already read that as well yeah just give
her everything give her everything
so give i'm sorry kelly kelly's looking
at us like what's going on so give her
ramsey plush that free degree
[Laughter]
kelly's about the cousins out but i'm
with the boss so i'm good well that's uh
ain't nothing new about that open phones
at triple eight eight two five
five two two five here's the thing
how do you eat an elephant
a bite at a time with a freaking plan
yes you don't randomly run up and take a
chunk out of it
that's good you've got a plan and you
execute
step by step by step through that plan
and it will take you into your future
and then when somebody asks you can say
i'm living the dream yes sir this is the
dave ramsey show
[Music]
do
so you hear wealth like i'm saying that
word a lot and you're probably in your
mind
thinking stereotypically what wealth or
what a millionaire looks like
and probably what i think of sometimes
right you see a millionaire
we'll say exhibit a this is lauren i'm
going to call her laura i have no idea
who she is but she looks
awesome and you probably have seen
lauren maybe on instagram or maybe in
your life
you have a lauren and lauren and her
husband
do really well they drive awesome cars
they go snow skiing every summer they go
to the beach twice a year with their
family
you know they're they're making together
like 000
a year they just bought a house that was
worth like two million dollars like
i mean just she's rich like you would
look at lauren and be like yeah
yeah y'all are doing really well like
you're rich yeah
then you see jane i calling her jane
i saw her picture earlier i was like
she's a jane super sweet like
jane's great right but like you know she
you know her clothes are pretty average
they drive used cars they live in a
pretty modest home her husband
together they make 90 000 a year so
pretty well but
nothing like extravagance
what if i were to tell you that actually
jane
is richer than lauren because here's the
reality you guys it's called your net
worth
your net worth is what you own minus
what you owe
equals your net worth but we don't know
here about lauren
sweet lauren yeah she's looking good on
the outside terrible on the inside
everything is on credit cards they have
car loans
they have a mortgage they actually put
nothing down on that brand new home they
bought and you think that they probably
paid cash for it they didn't they put
nothing down because they had nothing
they
live paycheck to paycheck they have no
investments they have no savings
they are stressed out that is lauren
jane jane well get out of here lauren
jane is actually amazing because they
have
a paid for house they just paid off
their house they have no car payments
they save for retirement so technically
jane's net worth
is more than lauren's and you guys like
this is like
not what we think of is it like again i
keep thinking over and over again like
we always see a picture of someone and
we automatically think oh i bet they're
really wealthy
but the people that are actually wealthy
in america today you don't even know who
they are because they're not on tv and
it's not all this glitz and glam
so for you guys not only do i want you
to get a
positive net worth but i want you to
start building
wealth so that you can change your
family and you can change other people's
lives because we say
to live like no one else so later you
can live and give
like no one else
hello hey guys we're here at blake
thompson's house and we're supposed to
shoot this video about saving money on
your electric bill but it uh
doesn't look like he's home but we're
not about to pack up waste all that gas
and drive back out here later
we're going to conserve that energy and
do this thing anyway
guess you don't need to lock your doors
around here and you know what they say
when the cat's away the mice will play
let's do this
turning your thermostat down 10 or 15
degrees for eight hours a day would
shave 15
off your bill smart thermostats make it
easy to set it and forget it
your water heater is probably set way
higher than it needs to be
turn that bad boy down to 120 degrees
and watch that bill drop
lighting takes up 25 percent of your
energy bill but led bulbs use 90
less energy and last up to 25 times
longer replace
five bulbs and you can save up to 75
bucks a year
up to 90 of your washing machines energy
goes to heating the water
skip the hot cycle and wash everything
on cold with a cold water detergent
your refrigerator is the only appliance
in the house that runs 24
7. save money by keeping the fridge temp
between 36 and 38
and the freezer between zero and five
even when your electronics are turned
off they're using phantom energy which
can amount to fifteen percent of your
build
plug all those gadgets into power strips
for one tap shut off like a box
george what are you doing here and
there's your minute money hack
get out
hey if you enjoyed this video we've got
a whole minute money hack playlist
waiting for you right here on our
youtube channel and if you've got some
energy saving tips we want to hear them
leave them in the comments below
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country or have a
better life
the army national guard can help get you
there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com to find out more
[Music]
hey folks it's george here to remind you
that christmas is almost
a month away and if you want some extra
cash i know just the place to get it go
to daveramsey.com
giveaway we're giving away five hundred
dollars every single week and a grand
prize of five
thousand dollars at the end of that so
go sign up you can check in every day
daveramsey.com
giveaway now it's veterans day and we
are celebrating this amazing couple
right here both
active duty air force and not only are
we celebrating for their sacrifice and
their service but they're also debt-free
how incredible is that
six figures paid off in under three
years this is a rock and roll couple
right here and i can't wait to hear
their story
[Music]
happy veterans today to all of those
that of you that are serving and have
served
on the debt-free stage we continue that
in the appropriate fatigues they're here
and uh
larry and melissa are with us from
phoenix uh right here on
the debt free stage in nashville hey
guys welcome
hi hello so you're obviously military
that or you went to a supply store
a surplus store right dave i think we
have our own
surplus store you got your own at home
yeah you've been serving a while have
you
okay what do you guys do in the military
uh so i'm public health
and i'm a military police officer public
health public health must be really
exciting right now in the military yes
sir
perfect time to serve wow yeah wow
amazing how long have you guys been in
uh 18 years both i've been at 17 years
okay did you meet there
in a military training class wow very
cool very cool
and both of you made a career out of it
thank you for your service yes
absolutely incredible all right how much
debt have you paid off uh we paid off
135 000.
very cool how long did this take two
years nine months
very good and your range of income
during that time about 137
to 147 very cool good
very neat what kind of debt was the 135
so it was all consumer
um just credit cards and car loans just
that simple yes sir
wow wow that's some nice cars yeah yes
sir
that or you just went hog wild on a
credit card i don't know a lot of
vacations
wow yes okay did y'all sell any of the
cars you just paid them off
so we traded in both okay um and got
different cars
um so we could get quick you know move
quicker through baby step two
yes got cheaper stuff cheaper stuff yes
okay so what did you sell
and what did you trade for uh so i sold
a gmc
acadia denali
i traded a cadillac cts coupe for a ford
escape
it was a sad day dave oh oh that one
hurts
that's not easy oh that hurts yes you
guys want it out of debt
we did fast wow that's impressive
now people had to be giving you a hard
time
yes yes they said we were crazy you go
from denali and cts
to escape and civic oh my god the
driveway's
the driveway cringe
that is awesome yes sir that had to be
that was really
all joking aside emotionally painful
days oh yeah i think more so for him
yeah i'm a car guy since i've been
younger i've drove nothing but sports
cars so going to the escape was a little
rough for me yeah that cts is a beast
too
i loved a great yes oh man
how many weeks later was it that you
just said
god i'm so smart
oh i said i said for me i don't know
you're still wondering
oh no oh no okay
you got outranked or something here i
don't know what happened it's true
all right very cool okay so um
well the good news is is that you've
lived like no one else now you can live
and drive
like no one else you'll be able to pay
cash and drive whatever you want um
so very very cool so what started this
intense
journey because you did a really hard
things on those cars
so we came home to water leaking through
the floorboards
uh that we had just charged fourteen
thousand dollars to install
oh no uh and we thought we were safe
with our home warranty that we had
purchased with this
with the you know selling it with the
buying of our home uh and unfortunately
that that didn't pan out for us
so uh we made a lot of tearful phone
calls to plumbers
but we didn't have any money uh the home
warranty wouldn't cover us we had no
money in savings and all of our credit
cards were maxed out
uh so the water was turned off and we
had three kids in the house
we were pushed pretty far to our limit
uh
and a plumber out of the kindness of his
heart or desperation in my voice i'm not
sure which one
uh actually ended up coming out that
night and it ended up being a small feat
it was only 75 dollars to fix the actual
problem
but unfortunately we went to bed with a
feeling of dread that night wow
so we went out the next day the library
and found the total money makeover
and uh read it out loud that weekend to
each other
cried a lot fought a lot and started
started baby step
one the next pay cycle wow that is uh
that's an intense process yeah
yeah ouch how long y'all been married
oh we just celebrated ten years in july
wow how old are your kids
uh so phoenix is 17. uh and then we have
noah who's six and lily is four
awesome very cool yes very cool wow
that was you know when you have
something that dramatic
that just hits you in the face you gotta
face it then
you can't you can't just walk away from
that i mean it's too in your face right
right so you had to do it both of you
and so that that's
that gives you enough emotional energy
to run through the
ctx to the ford focus move which it
takes some emotional energy to do that
right or the denali to the civic either
one but uh wow
wow i um again thank you for serving i
grew up as a military child and
some things probably have changed so
tell me but one of the things i see
common from back when i was living on in
fayetteville at fort bragg
i would see these young young guys get
their their signing bonuses get their
first check
and run to the car dealership and buy
the
the big nice brand new cars to that
young person listening to you today
what would you tell them that you wish
you knew when you all first started in
the military with all the great
benefits that you all receive so for me
i i work with probably like 30 young men
and women that are around in their
younger 20s yeah
and teens some of them and i explained
to them to do
not go out and get a car that you can't
afford
you know uh save your money many of them
have the money to buy a car in cash but
uh at the flashy thing that they
keep in the parking lot is what they
want and they think that's
you know like a show stopper but if they
save their money and they do right by
their money they can actually
drive whatever they want and that's
where i had to learn myself and i
i'm able to talk to them about that
because i've had to walk that line
myself
and uh hopefully for those out there uh
they do it the right way and they save
the money and buy
a nice car in cash yeah yeah
we've got a lot of chaplains teaching
financial peace university all over the
world
through the military and i've gotten the
opportunity to be on several
installations several bases around
and especially in america it amazes me
that when you leave the gates
there is stupid for two miles on both
sides of the road
like every dumb thing a 22 year old can
do
on the planet yeah stupid human tricks
stupid financial tricks whatever they
are
they're on both sides of the road for
two miles outside of every base
it's like the worst of the worst and
it's man i tell you you guys
that are officers and seniors and senior
uh people
have a real job you know just corralling
some 22 year olds that have our 21 year
olds left home for the first time and
keeping them out of that
that's a deal man it's a real deal i
think we focus on small goals for them
when we try to share our story we try
not to say hey pay off all your debt and
sell everything and don't eat out for
three years because then people are like
whoa no thank you
yeah um but we try to sell it to them um
you know in small doses and
one that's really effective is showing
them the calculator you know so if you
invest your car note
it'll grow to this much in 10 20 30
years that's a 5 million
car you're driving i hope you like it
exactly and then the 27
a day is 10 000 a year that seems to be
really effective
as well that's good i like it for me
very cool well thank you again thank you
for your service thank you for your
incredible story
because uh you guys went all in yeah i
mean you there's no question you've
completely
changed the way your brain works about
money i mean you've you blew up
everything
that that's it's very impressive it is
strenuous
that that much emotional shift in two
years and nine months is strenuous
it really is it adds a stress level to
your life to just have that much
transformation going on even though it's
positive you know so very very
very well done so very proud of you guys
got a copy of chris hogan's book for you
everyday millionaires we want that to
definitely be the next chapter
in your story and i think you're well on
your way and uh
the good news is larry yeah you're gonna
get a better car later
yeah don't worry dave already got that
good good i love it well i want you to
have a good car
these people driving a junk car and they
go that's my dave car i went wait a
minute
all right your dave cars when you get
rich and buy anything you want come on
that's your dave car
so let's get the kids in the picture
before we do the scream and introduce
some phoenix noah and lily are with us
to do the debt-free scream together with
their mom and dad
yeah dave phoenix couldn't make it today
noah and lily will be here today
perfect shout out to phoenix
all right count it down let's hear a
debt free scream three
two one we're dead free
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
everyone i've got a question for you do
you know your net worth
you see there's a lot of confusion out
there about net worth
i mean people think only celebrities
have a net worth that's not the case
everyone has one but what we have to do
is understand how to do this
well here's what you do net worth is
defined by taking what you
own minus what you owe and that gives
you your net worth
you see understanding this is crucial to
you beginning your journey to becoming
an everyday millionaire
we've got to know the start point but we
also have to have a game plan
that's why we developed the network
calculator it's six easy questions
tailored to help you to understand where
you are and to know your net worth
you can do this and i'm here to help all
you have to do is enter your email
address to get started
one of the things that makes the dave
ramsey show unique from other shows
is that we genuinely care about our
listeners
that's why we are very intentional about
choosing
our advertisers blinds.com
offers high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and then their customer service is truly
unbeatable
they make it simple to shop for blinds
shades and interior shutters from home
with easy online ordering and
free shipping right to your door and
blinds.com will help you every step of
the way
just like they've helped thousands of my
listeners
with free design help by phone and
online
plus they guarantee the perfect fit
go today and take advantage of this
week's
special offer
all right i am here with larry and
melissa and noah after an awesome debt
free scream they just stepped off the
stave
stage after a photo op with dave that's
always fun how you guys feeling
fantastic you should be your sacrifice
is amazing
uh both on the debt side and on the air
force side you guys are incredible it's
such such an honor to have you here
today
and the people out there are wondering
what is the new car you got
i got the lexus f sport lexus f sport
that's an upgrade i'll tell you that
much
and as a fellow honda civic owner i got
i love it okay it fits me you know i
just can never leave honda
i just love it listen hogan is the
denali and i'm the civic if we're gonna
make things clear here
so what's next for you guys now that
you're dead free oh gosh i mean and now
we're just
trying to save our money for when we
retire from the air force at this point
we sold our primary home to move on base
because we really didn't want to have
any debt and so that kind of catapulted
us to baby step five
and so we're investing appropriately and
saving for the kids college and just
preparing for that next transition once
we decide to retire
how does it feel to not go into debt for
college
see that's the thing he doesn't care yet
but one day he's gonna go mom dad my
friends are all drowning in student loan
debt
thank you so much for doing this for me
that's awesome what's your final
encouragement to some military families
out there who maybe are struggling where
you guys were a few years ago
right so it's just roll up the sleeves i
worked a second job never be too proud
to
work an extra job i was a janitor at a
ymca and i was in the military
so never be too proud and eventually
you'll drive a paid off lexus like me
there it is thank you guys for your
service thanks for being here thank you
so much
[Music]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality is my
co-host today here on the air
this is the dave ramsey show open phones
at triple eight
eight two five five two two five
jason is with us in detroit hi jason
welcome to the dave ramsey show
hey dave thanks for taking my call how
are you better than i deserve how can i
help
well i had a question for you um i've
been working with a financial advisor
who's given me some advice
and i follow the show i'm on baby step
seven currently
um but he presented me with an idea that
was a little outside the box
and i have term life insurance i've been
anti whole life
but he presented me with this infinite
banking concept
jesus you're kidding me it's monday yeah
i have excess money in a savings account
and looking to rebalance my portfolio to
get it to look a little bit harder
but my risk tolerance is a little bit
low and he showed me how you can do this
where you over
fund the whole life policy you can
access the money
you break even in year seven and then
the dividend outruns what you put into
it
yeah it's just it doesn't seem like a
terrible idea in that regard but i just
wanted your
your take on why you know that might not
be the best
the problem is that you where it gets
confusing
is that um god he's on a dividend
a financial advisor assistant this is an
insurance guy
well he's he's both they have you know
it's one of the bigger
companies um northwestern mutual or
prudential
exactly yeah okay he's an insurance guy
he's not a financial advisor
okay so because those are both mutual
companies now
there are two types of life insurance
companies mutual and stock
okay likely you bought your term unless
you bought it from him
from a stock company a stock company
stockholders owned the insurance company
a mutual company which is prue and
northwestern state farm is mutual is the
policy holders are actually the
stockholders
okay okay so when the
company makes a profit
the policy holders receive a dividend
as if they were a stockholder and
received a dividend
does that make sense yep yep now follow
the math here
if you are the owner of the company and
you're also the customer
of the company and the only place the
company gets money is from
the customers that are owners and they
give you
money from a profit by definition
that means it's because they took too
much from you
as a customer there wouldn't have been a
profit otherwise
okay so the irs has deemed consequently
that mutual life insurance company
dividends
are not dividends in the true sense of a
dividend
that instead they are and this is the
irs's language
they are instead a refund of a
deliberate
overcharge so they overcharge you in
order to give you some money later
to make you feel like you're making
money off of them
and it's absolute hogwash it's a pass
through mathematically it's a pastor
it's ha it's the way it has to be it's
the legal definition the freaking
company and the irs says so
so yeah the thing i didn't love is
you know you when you take the money
back you basically are paying an
interest rate on it
exactly and whose money is this
right that you're borrowing you're
borrowing your own money and you're
paying them interest
yep this is infinite banking for them
yeah yeah the infinite banking concept
is is
old school whole life done poorly
you need a real financial advisor not an
insurance broker that's trying to sell
you
a load of manure and so yeah the other
thing is that your cash values that are
sitting there
all die with you so whatever cash you
put into this
is equals zero at your death because
they only pay the face
value pro does not have a policy
northwestern mutual does not have a
policy that pays more than the face
value
except universal life b's which are not
in infinite banking products
and universal product b is where they
charge more than they usually charge
which basically buys the insurance so
they can still keep your money
is the way the math actually works on
this so you're dealing with one of the
most expensive
insurance products in the marketplace if
you're dealing with either one of those
two companies
i would stay completely away from both
of them
they're everyone in the financial field
except people that work for them
we all think they're a joke all of us
anyone who's academically trained or has
any kind of cfp
or anything else when they when someone
says they work for northwestern mutual
we just kind of laugh and go
yeah right you screw people every day
so dude you need to get away from them
and you need to go get a
real financial advisor that can help you
do some real
investing that takes into consideration
your low risk tolerance
low risk tolerance does not need to lead
you to losing your money
100 of the cash invested at death
yeah that's a bad risk tolerance thing
so you need to move on dude you need to
move on but because the
and the whole thing of the dividends are
paying for it
is such a joke because the dividends are
the refund of a deliberate overcharge
so who's paying for it if you're getting
dividends from if you owned home depot
stock and you got dividends from that
then home depot's making a profit but
they're making a profit off of their
customers yes and i'm the owner
of the investment i get that dividend
that's different
then if i am the customer and i'm the
stockholder
thereby the only way i made a profit was
off of me
myself so i pay you an extra hundred
bucks and then you give me 70 of it and
i'm supposed to feel great about that
right
yeah so that's what this amounts to and
so you guys
working with state farm when you get
your little dividend check that's what
it is
it's the refund of a deliberate
overcharge
irs verbatim says that yeah
and that's why you don't get taxed on it
if you get a dividend on home depot
stock
you get taxed on it as income because
it's real income
you really made an investment and then
you really made an income
so that's what's going on with that
stuff and so do not buy
anything in the life insurance world
based on
dividends uh you look at the price look
at the structure of the policy
and uh you'll usually find that mutual
companies by the way are the higher
priced
so when you go to a quote service
like a zander insurance and you get
quoted on term life insurance
you're going to find no mutual companies
in the 42
different companies that they give you a
quote from because they're not
competitive
why because they charge more so they can
give some of it to you back later
and make you feel like that you got
something that's really what it amounts
to and that's why you won't find them
they're not competitive
yeah dave you're fired up about this one
man i'll tell you what pisses me off
infinite banking my butt
infinite banking is for them yes the
only listen the only thing you that that
agent has for his whole life is a need
for your commission to be paid to him
absolutely that's the only whole life
thing that is involved here
uh this these products are horrendous
yeah
and you know it's bad enough when they
feed on
the middle class but that guy's a baby
step seven man he's probably a
millionaire yeah
and and they create such a jumbled
word picture that you can't cut through
the bs and yet you know the thing about
him
here's did you notice what happened with
him this is interesting
you know it didn't feel right yeah
yeah he felt it didn't yeah he felt it
and that's probably because he's going
through our process and he knows what we
teach
well it's not just that he didn't just
say well dave says it's wrong right he's
there's something wrong here i just
can't put my finger on it yeah overpay
and get money back but i mean you ever
have those feelings i don't know exactly
what's wrong
but i smell a rat yeah which means
there's a dead rat in the corner
somewhere i just hadn't found him yet or
below the couch something stinks in here
something stinks in here something got
in the house and died
you know i got a smell in here what is
it something's wrong you got you can't
find it
you can't put your finger on but how
many times have you been in a situation
with a person
or with a product a financial product
you know you had one
you had one you were buying an item i
won't say what it was on the air
but you got the smell off the people and
you ran and what
three weeks ago what was it dave tell me
how you gotta have me
what was it i'm not going to because
because they might be listeners and i'm
not gonna do that to you i'm gonna throw
you under the bus
you walked out of a deal into a
different deal
not long ago oh yes sir right was it not
the same thing
it was the exact holy spirit inside of
you said i smell
a wrap something's not right
something be wrong with these people
iran this deal
is there i can't put my finger on it but
this deal is bad yes
and you ended up in another deal there's
a much better deal because you listened
even though you couldn't logically
explain it you could listen to your
heart
absolutely listen to the bell when the
bell rings
it's called the holy spirit yeah this is
the dave ramsey show
[Music]
people call my show all the time
complaining
about how awful their timeshares are
and i've been saying this for years
don't do it
what's going on out there that's content
allowing this industry to just continue
dave it's greed and honestly this isn't
going to change
until the industry decides to recognize
that they have a customer service
nightmare because of a terrible product
they're not taking care of their of
their customers which is why we're
flooded with calls every day
time sure exit team is different i mean
we we now have
you know almost 20 000 people out of
timeshare contracts
actual results actual results big deal
yes
if you need out timeshare exit team
is the team the only team
that i trust to help you schedule your
free consultation
by calling 844 999
exit or timeshareexitteam.com
[Music]
we met at wisconsin bible church and
he being a pilot and my dad being a
pilot met
we got to know each other and and then
we got to chatting on the phone and
kind of just took off from there and
became friends her dad had given me a
book
when we first got married dave's one of
dave's first books and financial piece
and we had read that we had i had
student loan debt
pretty considerable amount of debt for
the amount of money he was making but
other than that we didn't have any
credit card debt
or car payments or anything like that
but what caused us to decide to get out
of debt was
airlines are pretty fickle so so the
turning point for me was uh
knowing that we had too much debt and
that i could possibly lose my job and
not be able to function for even a month
i couldn't fill my car with gas one
month because
we had less than a hundred dollars in
the bank that feeling at the pump i was
like i will never
ever be in this again
my name is will and this is my wife
kelly and um we live in waisola alaska
and
i work for as a pilot for alaska
airlines and
i am a photographer horse trainer
adventure wife with will
[Music]
so when we got married that was one of
the big things he was very spontaneous
he was very spontaneous and i was very
much
a planner and we clashed a lot and we
look at each other and we go
oh my gosh i'm so thankful that we
agree and and we talk through
things when maybe we have different
ideas and then
figure out how to combine those ideas we
set goals every year
on our anniversary we talk money goals
and
we always exceeded them it was really
amazing actually
oh gosh when every dollar came out that
was
amazing and the but the every dollar at
the budget is the most
other than being on board with one
another and having the same goal it's
the most crucial aspect
of getting out of debt yeah you cannot
lollygag yeah
because you can save thousands of
dollars
a year by budgeting and knowing what you
spend
i don't know we spent this whole last
year at free and it was really cool
yeah that was amazing every penny coming
in it didn't have to go out unless we
wanted it to
that was a really crazy feeling
[Music]
so
would you rather save money and i know
it's not a lot of money you're saving
but would you rather save money by
having to share a toothbrush
with your spouse or having to share
deodorant
with your spouse deodorant
deodorant i've used her deodorant a few
times so it works
okay that's what that's like if you're
cool with i wear
perfume deodorant sometimes you do what
so you're sharing a toothbrush today
anthony i'm ma i'm not married i'm
saying
so i see you guys you're talking about
your future wife
yeah so would you have to share your
toothbrush or deodorant
is she gonna have to wear your deodorant
i mean well the only person she's
kissing is me so i'd do the toothbrush
deodorant i want that manly smell all
right you see what i'm saying
yeah i want that manly smell with no
perfume deodorant on me
you know because if i got to argue she's
gonna i want this dove actually
no i just need that clean stuff and
toothbrush i'm good i mean the only
person she kissing is me now we gotta
talk about what you're gonna eat
throughout that day you know but
hey dj tell them dove ain't that bad i
know you put on some dove i mean
dove is cool i rock with dub but i do
man duff i don't do that
that girly dub but he don't mind doing
what his wife does
secret hey you know something yeah is
coming to your side of the
sink to get your deodorant hurts right
there
ah oh bad but bro
i can't do that because sometimes what
if i don't take a shower i just put a
deodorant on you know i gotta be like
hmm
hey man you know but you know i think i
really do honestly believe
both are neither wrong when you're
married i mean you know
you're married hey george's mining mine
is yours
there you go see but with govid going on
you're probably safe for sharing
deodorant right
probably a little bit i chose deodorant
is because if you think about it
if someone does something to your
toothbrush that you don't like
for me i take that personally you're
saying drop my toothbrush on the floor
he looked at his wife i dare you
you know i love this couple man hey
there y'all have fun together i
i love it he looked there like i dare
you to drop my toothbrush
hey hey dj i'm right there with you bro
i got some flower dove on right now
use my wife's this morning so flower
dove on with the cavaliers sweatshirt
hey
c is for connor dude coca-cola
coca-cola not a sponsor
[Music]
the total debt is around six hundred and
forty thousand dollars
i'm wanting to come clean about a credit
card that he doesn't know about i'm
gonna probably pay
student loans for the rest of my life i
just don't even know where to begin
and i don't know what to do i'm not
scared welcome to the dave ramsey show
you are not a victim you are the hero in
your story
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career everything just
started making sense i was like i'm
gonna
do this let's hear a debt-free scream
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's
the dave ramsey show where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice anthony
o'neil ramsey personality number one
best-selling author of the book
debt-free degree is my co-host today on
the air we're talking to you
about your life and about your money
open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five triple eight
eight two five five two two
five shawn is in grand rapids michigan
hey sean welcome to the dave ramsey show
hey dave hey anthony hey what's up man
um not much i'm just wondering
so i'm on baby step four i guess
um and what the only reason i say i
guess is because
um look because i've completed steps one
two and three
okay but i just don't know like how
interested i am at actually saving for
retirement
because i don't know if i could ever
like envision myself
actually retiring
i'm so confused right now um how old are
you right now sean i'm 25
how old will you be next year
26 in february okay so
do you see where i'm going here yeah
so you're saying you're getting
yeah and i get you let me let me let
i probably started out that offroad and
i got dave started i'm sorry
no um i like it why bring out the sass
early
25 years old are you not motivated to
start thinking about your future hey
let's try this what if we change the
word
from retirement to rich i like that word
i mean i really like the sound of that
too it's the same thing dude
yeah i understand that but i just really
enjoy
working me too i don't i plan to work
until i die
a matter of fact i'm going to stay
around here and just spread hate and
descension in this building oh no you're
not
well i certainly hope so i'll be old and
old and dementia crept in
and i'll just not be making sense on the
air and james i'll have to be hitting
the dump button nah
we'll fix that
and this is what i'm thinking like at
that point like say i were
to go out of my mind like dementia
like cannot can physically not work
anymore
um couldn't i just have money in the
bank
to be able to take care of that yeah the
problem is the bank
pays crap yes like two percent no and i
yeah so let's pretend let's pretend that
you
retire you reach an old age whatever you
want to call
old at 25 years old i'm 60 so old now is
a lot older than it used to be
so but if let's just pretend you reach
old age
and you either have a million dollars
or you don't right
one life is better than the other one
yeah
then you make choices about whether you
want to work or not work
dude i haven't had to work in years
right
i've had financial peace a long time
yeah
i work when i want to work what you're
doing yeah
and so you do the same thing man build
you up some wealth
and so i think what you're confusing is
is that you think you have to sit on a
dock and fish
at 55 years old and maybe catch a fish
and just get a sunburn
and you call that retirement retirement
to us means you got a huge pile of money
and you could spend the next 30 years
giving it giving it away
and never have given it all away because
the pile was so huge
yeah yeah yeah yeah and i think he says
you know sean i really want you to think
about your future
you're thinking about 55 what if you
could retire at 45 what do you
what if he could be like dave and myself
because you know i'm in financial peace
i don't work i actually enjoy
doing what i do with dave and our team
here this is not a nine to five like i
got to get up and have to go do this
this is i love helping people what if
that could be you at 35
at 45 but you have to start practicing
these principles
now yeah okay and and listen the the
a million dollars in your mutual funds
at retirement is not a lot
but it gives you a lot more choices than
not having any money
at retirement and depending on the
government for social insecurity yes
and so you do not want the mantra of
your life to go
i'm going to work all my life and hope
the government which is well known for
its ability to handle money will take
care of me
that's not a good plan so yeah you need
the point is not retirement the point is
build wealth yeah
that's it that's the point so just
change your vernacular on it change your
verbage on it yes and maybe that'll
change the way you're looking at it now
how do we build wealth the most
efficient way to build wealth
is in tax free growth
which happens to be in this thing called
a retirement plan yes
a roth yes but that's the most efficient
way to build
wealth yes keep the government's
freaking hands off your money
absolutely and that you know or i paid
for real estate which then it grows
without any taxes on the growth until
you sell it capital gains growth is not
taxable
it's realized but not recognized under
tax law and so you can do stuff like
that but become
wealthy so that you can not only live
your
best life not only be outrageously
generous to others
but someday you might have a family and
you actually want to change
your family tree the bible says a good
man leaves an inheritance to his
children's
children now that's what we're talking
about dave now i'm getting legacy legacy
that's that's that's this is not
retirement this is a
money it's wealth yeah yeah and so it
happens to be
that the most the first steps to
becoming wealthy
and the most tax efficient investments
are those
inside of retirement plans but if we
just take the word retirement off of and
call
this is the best way to get rich yeah
yeah
then it changes your mindset maybe and
and dave you know i i want to i want to
want i want to stay right there with you
because you've taught me so much
from joining your team and really just
learning from you watching what you do
for your family
here's another reason why i'm always
recommending to millennials so think
about
rich think about wealth towards
retirement not just towards retirement
because
what can you leave down to your
children's children steve harvey was on
the show with oprah winfrey a while back
and
he was telling the story of how his
great-great-grandmother
was passing away and she asked steve she
said steve do you know your great
grandfather's name
he said no she said do you know why and
he said no she said because he didn't
leave you anything
and that shook me when i was watching
rob and i said
i don't want to die and my children's
children
don't even know my name yeah i mean the
vanderbilt's no cornelius
[Laughter]
you know i mean really let's be real i
got a picture of the
of the commodore over the dead
over the mantle baby you know and when i
look at you
your your grandchildren's children will
know your name
and i went the other way i stirred up a
ruckus you did
and i helped i helped you build it well
we helped you build it
and so we are you know that's for me is
that's why you know i i want my
grandchildren
and i i wrote a vow to my kids i said
hey the idea
is not wealth for wealth's sake money
just to pile it up that's mental illness
there you go dave okay but the money's
only good for a couple things yes sir
give it yes sir enjoy it yes sir
and and have long-term eternal impact
including the changing of your family
tree there you go
and so when you can take some money and
reach over and change the destiny of
somebody's life
change the direction the trajectory of
someone's life and they might actually
akin to you
yes sir like your great-grandbabies yes
sir then money has had a value at that
point there you go but just piling it up
to say i'm rich nobody i mean that's
shallow yeah nobody gives a crap what
car you drive
that's sure shallow shallow
girl wants to date you for what car you
drive don't let her go come on now be
impactful for your future not impressive
all right this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
there's there's a turning point at which
we were just like oh we hate debt
but then there was also a second turning
point
of going from we hate the mindset of
high
we hate debt to we want
to be really good stewards of
our money and and that that was another
shift
let's not just stop here at the student
loans
let's tackle the house now too
as i got raises we never changed our
lifestyle we would
put every single raise into the house
as the numbers started going down we
passed the
200 000 mark and that was really cool to
watch that number go to a one that was a
big deal
and when we passed the hundred thousand
it was like we were on a roll
it was just what we were doing i think
it was just more of a slog
yeah i mean yeah you're at the base of a
big mountain
we had a trip planned down to the kenai
peninsula it's about
a four hour drive out of anchorage and
we realized that trip coincided
with the month that we were gonna pay
the house off
we're known as kind of like the crazy
adventure
couple we go and do things that most
people would not do
cal polex that were doing an adventure
and and they paying off our house in the
process of it
it took us eight and a half years to pay
off my student loans in the house
it was it was long in fact we've talked
about it recently i don't think we
realized
what kind of a sacrifice it was until
after we were done
it became the normal yeah it became
normal we started with a
nearly quarter million dollars of
negative net worth
and we could call in and do the
millionaire hour thing you know probably
in the next year
and that's not that's not at all the
brag that's simply a
the way the plan is set up it works
you know when you own your house you can
take two paths you can make more money
or you can
spend time with your family and that's
the that's the
branch that i would like to take is is
more quality time
being able to dream uh bigger than we
ever thought
possible i mean when you start talking
millions of dollars and what you could
do with that
the way it would affect your life it's
pretty incredible
yeah with all the young couples out
there
if you start starting now you'll be
blown out of the water what you can do
and make goals dream big
[Music]
one of the things that makes the dave
ramsey show unique from other shows
is that we genuinely care about our
listeners
that's why we are very intentional about
choosing
our advertisers blinds.com
offers high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and then their customer service is truly
unbeatable
they make it simple to shop for blinds
shades and interior shutters from home
with easy online ordering and
free shipping right to your door and
blinds.com will help you every step of
the way
just like they've helped thousands of my
listeners
with free design help by phone and
online
plus they guarantee the perfect fit
go today and take advantage of this
week's
special offer
[Music]
hey uh
open phone's a triple eight eight two
five five
two two five i never do that that's
funny all mics are hot fool
all right jump in the phone number is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five anthony o'neil
is the ramsey personality co-host for
today
hanging out with me learning how not to
do radio
if you haven't heard we're giving away
cash the ramsey christmas giveaway is
underway
congratulations to natasha from
idaho you just won five hundred dollars
whoa
our team will be in touch you were drawn
for this week
every week between now and christmas
we're giving away 500 bucks
with a 5 000 grand prize uh be sure you
jump on at daveramsey.com
giveaway and register every day
no purchase is necessary if you're
looking for life-changing gifts for
family and friends today we are running
a
one-day sale for the first time ever you
can get our starter
envelope system for five dollars
pick one up for yourself your family
your friends while they're 72
off and shop over 50 of our best-selling
books for only ten dollars
those five dollar envelope systems make
uh it makes a pretty good stocking
stuffer
so daveramsey.com giveaway check out the
one day sale
five dollars each on the famous starter
envelope system
72 percent off and 50 of our books
all best sellers only ten dollars each
including
john deloney's new quikry oh that's and
it's
kind of blowing off the shelf it really
is redefining
anxiety yeah this guy
which he's helped us do that because
we're working with him
good point dave good boy will is with us
wills in denver
hey well welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi dave hi
anthony house tennessee i'm actually
headed to nashville tomorrow it's
amazing yeah come on brother we'd love
to have you
i'm looking forward to it i want to try
one of those cookies i've been hearing
about them for years
so uh i just moved to denver and i'm
working on baby step 3b as best i can
my current plan is to pause my
retirement and save all my extra money
in like an s p
500 index fund for about five years
but pausing my retirement for that long
scares me a little should it
yes yes absolutely we usually say about
three yeah
five five feels long how old are you
uh i'm 31. okay that's that's not the
end of the world
yeah but i just don't i the thing is we
just don't want you to
just not save money for retirement for
an extended period of time
so how much you're trying to save
um i mean kind of five years i was going
to try to see if i could
manage to pull off 100 grand that'd be
difficult but
planning on putting all my bonuses 500 a
month um
i got a relocation package recently i
put half of it in there
um but i do have in the s p thinking
it'd be a five year plan but you're
telling me three now i'm wondering if an
index fund is a great
move well you're probably okay yeah how
much do you make a year will
uh 65. okay how much of a house are you
trying to buy eventually
um oh with denver i mean by the time
three years is up they could all be a
million plus but uh
i'm thinking can maybe pull off between
like 250 and three to start with a condo
or something
yeah okay okay that's good yeah well you
probably don't need a hundred down to do
300k no um so
uh you may want to shorten the term just
a little bit uh
and or lower the down payment yeah uh my
it might mean both but
i i'm five years is max yeah i mean i i
really we usually say three
yeah uh and you know if you've got some
time and you want to go that route i
don't have any problem with it if you're
doing five years and you
ended up with 100 down because of
something happened um oh you know what
we're not calculating here we're not
calculating the fact your income is
going to go up during that time
yeah i was about to see you being
generous for five years hopefully
yeah i'm saying three no more than three
man yeah that's that's generally where
we are you know what i would do is i
would do it do it for three years and
then
give yourself permission to change the
plan yes
you don't have to keep doing that just
because you started that way you could
go three and go
okay i'm buying or three and you look at
it you go i've made a lot more money if
i go one more year i'll stretch it to
four
i can get there but i don't want this to
drag out and you look up and it's been
10 years
yeah that wouldn't be the way i would
change the plan right
so good question good question matthews
with us matthew is in new york city hi
matthew how are you
hey how we doing great man how can we
help
so i'm curious as to your opinion i'm
considering moving out of my mother's
apartment where i lived with her and my
sister i'm only 20 years old
is this the good move or is this not a
good move
uh are you doing anything what are you
doing with your life right now are you
in school are you
working what are you doing so currently
i do school
probably in class about 15 20 hours and
studying another
10 and then i work full time in a
restaurant about 45 hours a week
what do you make yeah i am
currently making i'd say net
income about 52 000 a year net income 52
000 a year working how many hours
about 45 to 50. and going to school 15.
oh okay all right correct how much
longer do you have in school
uh only two years left okay
are you cash flowing this this school
right now are you are you taking out
student loans
so the first two years that i'm doing at
community college my parents saved up
money to pay for these following two
years
i'm taking on myself but the loan is
coming from the family member and i have
to pay them off let's say every three
months still interest
and everything is lenient payments
what what school are you going to your
second year how much is going to cost
you a semester let me ask that question
because i'm not a huge fan of our money
from family yeah no opening hoping to
try to go to rutgers or
kane university one of the state
colleges in jersey
average cost between the three probably
eleven thousand and
000 not living on campus yeah
so dave may think differently but i'm
going to say if you're making 50 000
i'm going to stay home and cash flow
the next two years and not borrow money
not accept money from the family member
so here's the thing what is
the goal okay in my mind if i'm in your
shoes but you need to ask yourself what
is the goal
if my mind is not uh how you have not
got
any time to party right you work all the
time and go to school all the time yeah
and so being at your mama's house is not
a problem for you right
in that regard so what is the goal the
goal is to complete the education
with no debt if i'm in your shoes that's
the goal
uh the independence you're 20 years old
uh you know what do you gain
because every dollar you spend to move
out
takes you away from your goal come on
yeah right yep
and so what are you gaining for that
move
that's what you've got to ask yourself
and so if you can do both i'm okay with
it there's nothing evil about moving out
and getting on your own
but let's say you move out and you spend
two thousand dollars
a month yeah to live outside and that
ends up that you take 24 000
out of loans from the relative yes then
basically you borrowed money to live out
of your mama's house
that's it don't tell me you borrowed it
for school no he bought it for lifestyle
and to get out from under mama's thumb
and so you know that's the effect of
what's going on so
uh uh if you could accomplish all of
these things and move out
fine no problem no problem
but it i don't think you can yeah
financially i don't think the math is
going to work because you live
in a you know one of the most expensive
places in the world live
and so when you move out you're going to
have an expensive place to live and it's
going to be a tiny tiny
tiny tiny little apartment he's living
in a tiny apartment
with a roommate teeny tiny apartment
yeah so that's why i'm saying
i would say go in ahead and stay at home
be very strategic though while you're at
home
make sure you don't borrow nothing from
a family member graduating
yeah graduate 100 debt free and all the
extra money
now start saving that so that way you
are prepared to move out when you
graduate with the savings account
because you will need that energy so
here's what here's one thing
the the the reason that most of us don't
hit our goal
is not that we didn't know what the goal
was it's that we develop a competing
goal there you go
and the two goals compete with each
other and you end up hitting neither one
of them
right okay right i have a goal to eat
this box of donuts
right but also have a go to lose weight
these are competing goals
you can't do that all right so
in your case what i would say is it's a
lesser goal
to move out than it is to graduate
debt-free nice so if you put enough
money in the bank to graduate debt-free
and move out yes then move out but until
then i wouldn't i like it dave
we agree on this one yes it's good that
we agree
it's a brain trust yes this is the dave
ramsey show
[Music]
here's the next one and you're not gonna
like it
you gotta fail i want you to fail at
something
i want you to go out there and just suck
at something i want you to go out there
and say you know what
i don't i don't know what i'm about to
do but i'ma try it anyways
you know i want you to do it when i
first started this youtube channel oh we
sucked
we weren't getting no views we people
weren't looking at me
when i first got on the stage and
preached my first sermon oh it was
horrible
it was horrible when i got my first job
oh man it was just bad it was just bad
but everything that i failed at taught
me something
and so today i'm the man i am because i
can look back at the things that i
failed at
this generation of young people we want
to just
be owners and entrepreneurs and just
rise to the top
but we don't want to go through the
proper steps to get there
i was talking my mentor dave ramsey the
other day on the show and i said dave
you know talk to these young
entrepreneurs or these young people
in their 20s and 30s who want to start a
business he was like go fail at
something
you know how many mistakes i've made
here ramsey solutions
you know how many more mistakes i have
to make before i get to run a
billion dollar organization i'm not
scared to fail because every time i fail
i learned and every time i learn
i improve when i improve i grow
fail learn improve and grow
if you ain't failing at something you
ain't going nowhere
if your friends are not failing at
something y'all ain't going nowhere
and that's one thing i love about
quality relationships i don't mean to go
back
but every time we we get around a circle
and and if we fail at something we bring
it to the table
one of my one of my boys were crying i'm
gonna be real with you i felt that a
relationship
i was engaged and i went around that
circle and i cried
and the very first question they asked
me what did you learn
from the relationship check this out not
about her
but about yourself that you won't bring
to the next relationship
i failed i learned i
improved and i'm still improving
and because i'm still improving i'm
growing
but i can't grow without failing fail
at something
[Music]
hey guys by now you know about financial
peace university
this is the class that teaches you the
proven plan to take control of your
money
get out of debt and build wealth over
six million people
have done this and on the front lines
are these people called coordinators
that are leading these classes
all across the country they invest their
time to help other people
like you win with money and you can be
one of them
but we reached out to them to figure out
why they do this thing in the first
place
here's what they had to say the reason
why i lead this class is not that
complicated
i want my students to crush debt and to
be irritated
like david those who want to steal and
keep you from your money
those credit cards and student loans
that tempt and call you honey
i teach the baby steps all of them from
one to seven
and when you're through with them you'll
almost feel like you're in heaven
but you're still here because you're
focused and not finished yet big pop
chris hogan man reminding you to not
forget to budget
to give each dollar a job we're talking
zero based and having some cash saved up
when murphy gets up in your face
now delegate 15 you know it's for your
future
make sure your kid has cash for school
so he won't be no moocher
now go and pay your home real fast
attack that mortgage loan
as dave would say the grass feels
different on the land you own
now fpu is more than building wealth
just for yourself because
if you just stick to the plan you'll
live and give like no one else
that's why i'm an fpu coordinator that
was
awesome listen if you want to make an
impact and help others win with money
you can lead a financial peace
university class which is now a part
of ramsay plus you don't have to have
gone through the class before
you don't have to be debt free and you
don't have to be a financial expert
you just have to have a heart to serve
others and a commitment to what we teach
our team does all the teaching and we
make it super easy
and fun to lead plus you can lead a
class from anywhere
oh and coordinators get some sweet perks
for leading too
to get started just text the word life
changer to 33789
and we'll send you a link with all the
info you need to help others find
financial peace
again that's life changer all one word
to 33789
cliff and i joined christian healthcare
ministries because we really liked the
concept of
christians sharing each other's burdens
and we really experienced that
firsthand when cliff was diagnosed with
heart disease
christian healthcare ministries or chm
is not health insurance
but rather a federally approved
exemption to the health care law
it's a time-tested model to help take
care of your healthcare costs
it's christians helping other christians
by sharing each other's medical bills
adjusting to a new system of paying for
healthcare
was kind of tricky but that's where chm
stepped in
and they really helped navigate that
water
with the hospital and the payment want
to see if chm is the right fit for your
health care needs
check out our website at
chministries.org backslash budget
that's ch chministries.org backslash
budget it was just such a relief to know
that financial burden was going to be
taken care of
[Music]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality is
my co-host today
calling from suffolk virginia on
veterans day
cody and kalyn are with us to do a
debt-free scream congratulations guys
hi thank you well done
so you guys you guys serve or one of
your serves who's in the military
uh yes i am i'm in the military i'm in
the navy okay cool what do you do in the
navy
i'm a aviation electrician awesome
how long have you served i've been in
for
14 years wow thank you thank you for
your service
we're doing all veterans and active duty
debt-free screams today on the air to
say thank you to
all of you folks we appreciate all of
you so how much debt have you paid off
cody and kalyn
we paid off 33 900
and how long did this take eight months
wow you knocked it all right and your
range of income during that eight months
we were on a salary of 75 000.
okay so just locked in that was it okay
cool what kind of debt was the 34
000 we had two vehicles
uh credit card and uh store credit for
some smart phones
so you guys are kind of normal pretty
much yeah
how long y'all been married 12 years
wow what happened eight months ago that
literally on fire because you guys went
crazy
[Music]
um so i'm a photographer by trade
but i set it aside to homeschool seven
years ago
i was serving my church and as a
photographer and i wanted to
get a better camera and so i started
side hustling to get a new camera and
get it up to date so i can better
serve it serve my team and uh it took
six months and i saved up what i needed
and afterwards i looked at cody and i
was like all right what's our next goal
like what can i save for now and he said
i want a garage
and i was like well my side hustle is
not going to fund that
but if we pay off the cars that might
fund it
and so then we kind of remembered dave
ramsey from
you know many years ago the foundations
were there from when we were newlyweds
and it just kind of
put us back on track and um yeah we
just went straight to it wow okay so
when you were newlyweds you went through
financial piece or you just had heard
the name ramsay
um so when we were newlyweds my aunt jan
and uncle john
did our first budget with us wow and
they gave us total money makeover and
they gave us the old cds
to uh financial peace military
okay good very good so you kind of did
like a self-led
so you drug them back out yeah well
i just started listening to the podcast
and then um
i would every time we here in hampton
roads there's a lot of commuting and so
every time i was in the car i would just
listen to it
and um yeah it got us got us motivated
you hear the debt free screams i would
on
like goosebumps every time some of them
i would cry
like i can't wait to do one my kids
would say the same thing
i love it how many kids have you got
what ages
uh we got three kids wow two boys and a
girl how old are they
uh the oldest boy is ten years the
second boy is seven and the girl is
three years old
okay nice so you look in those faces
that also gives you some motivation
right
yes of course so so now let me ask you
this uh caitlyn and cody
uh what was the hardest thing during
this journey
paying off 33 000 900
within eight months what was the thing
that you all had to really get over
together as a couple
um so one of our biggest struggles was
we had
we were paying off debt but we still had
a credit card um and it was a zero
percent
and in our head we were like oh it's
zero percent but we didn't
realize how much of a ball and chain
that was around our legs like we only
shopped
at that one store um because
it we had a credit card there and it was
like you don't realize how
like tied down you are to it um and so
when we created this thinking fund for
it
and it's our home improvement fund so i
won't say the store but we
we you know stopped using that credit
card created a thinking fund
specifically for home improvement
and now we're free to shop wherever we
want we're not tied down to that store
turns out lowe's has deals and sodas
home depot
[Music]
exactly and sometimes they're
alternating
yeah absolutely absolutely so it is
amazing how
not only do they make a killing on those
car store cards but how they also create
a
brand loyalty with them because you know
i would never think of going to lowe's i
have my home depot card i mean it's just
ridiculous how our brains work i do
we've all done that same thing sears
started it sears did dave a million
years ago
and look where they ended up yep bk
okay so there you go they even started
discover card
they did they did and sold it when they
went bankrupt so there you go
the first time they went bankrupt so
anyway i love these stories but anyway
way to go
guys you broke free yes so uh
what was you who were your biggest
cheerleaders
our kids yeah wow so they've been
practicing their debt free scream
they have because i hear them in the
background they're ready to go they're
pumped oh
my three-year-old oh my gosh i i'm gonna
take a video of her debt-free scream
just by herself because it's amazing
yeah post it post it on youtube with us
okay okay i will that'd be cool i love
it
yeah so that's candy right that's candy
yeah i love it yeah that's fun
all right guys we're proud of you again
thanks for serving we got a copy of
chris hogan's book for you everyday
millionaires that's the next chapter in
your story
34 000 dollars paid off in eight months
making 75
000 cody kalyn carter chris and candy
from virginia count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
way to go kids you stole the show man
you hear the kids louder than you hear
the parents
you know and what's weird is when you're
10 years old
yeah you'll tell your grandkids yes
about when your family tree changed yep
we called in this radio show
they used to have these things called
radio shows back then used to
and there was this guy on the radio
who's crazy yeah and my mom listened to
him all the time on this old thing they
used to call podcasts
she decided we were going to get out of
debt and that's why honey
that we don't have any money problems a
generation later that's the sound of a
family tree being changed right there
you heard it
ah man i love it i love it too i mean
the money's the money the math change is
important yes
but when the kids get it like that and
the kids have been practicing
it's drilled into yeah you can't get
away from it
no i mean they get married they're 22
years old and their their
their new spouse wants to go out and get
a credit card and go into debt they're
gonna go no
nope nope it's all because their brains
are changed
yeah it's it's reset i love it and
these debt-free screams are not just
about money dave they're about life
change
it's about freedom yes sir you can hear
it that's why everybody cries and gets
goosebumps when you hear them you know
what freedom sounds like
our question today comes from blinds.com
they have a 100
satisfaction guarantee even if you
mismeasure you must make the wrong
color they'll remake your window blinds
for free always use the promo code
ramsey to get the best deal
today's question comes from elise in
california i have about five student
loans totaling two twenty six thousand
dollars
during the pandemic and while the
interest rate is at zero percent i have
managed to pay off one of the loans
unfortunately
i owe taxes for 2019 to both the federal
and the state totaling about five
thousand dollars
i have been making monthly payments to
both of
uh with two hundred dollars each and an
extra monthly payment
of four hundred dollars to my student
loans should i hold off on the student
loans to knock out my
taxes i'm knocking out my taxes because
i don't want to get any
issues with them down the road and then
immediately getting back onto my
student loan payments absolutely that's
exactly the right answer
absolutely and you do not want the kgb i
mean the irs in your life
you do not want them there yeah you
don't and uh they have unbelievable
penalties
unbelievable interest yes unbelievable
power to
screw up your life yes you want them out
of your life as soon
as possible yeah yeah and other thing is
uh why are you five thousand dollars
short on your 2019s have you gone back
and show
changed your withholding so that you're
not short on 2020 yes sir
2020 is over you may have another 5k
waiting on you right around the corner
if you hadn't gonna fix that dead gum
with holding because you're under
withholding apparently yep
unless something else happened that's
the only explanation for that
mathematically
yeah this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
some of the biggest aha moments i've had
in life is when i've realized and
learned more about who
i am and why i am the way i am when i
have more self-awareness i realize well
i win more
in my marriage with my kids at work and
other relationships in life
and so as i was on that journey i
started to realize wow what if i took
some of that self-awareness and applied
it to my money
understanding not just how to handle my
money but
why i handle money the way i do so in my
new book
know yourself know your money we're
going to go underneath the foundation of
all the money principles i've been
talking about for over a decade
so besides just budgeting and getting
out of debt and saving and retirement
and insurance
all these principles we talk about when
we go underneath the foundation and
start talking about not just
how you handle money but why you handle
money the way you do
i promise that self-awareness will help
you win with money
faster and this book is going to give
you the fuel
and the hope to cause it to happen
[Music]
[Applause]
a lot of things that we've experienced
that are just kind of
shaped us and made us who we are i'm
vanessa maureen
and this is my husband eloy mourin and
we've been married 10 years today it's
our wedding anniversary
the accident that was a huge turning
point for us
i just said babe i just need to pray and
i said i don't know what's going to
happen but i love you
no matter what i love you and if i'm not
here anymore it'll be okay
so tired of life happening to us
from now on i'm gonna start happening to
life and at that moment
everything changed like my mindset
changed i
felt it the environment changed the
atmosphere changed we held tight
and we just said this is what we said i
do years back and we're going to keep
marching forward just going to keep
going life hit us
really hard but life is not bigger than
god
not the god we serve it's not i know
that he has great plans for us
absolutely
step one one thousand dollars to start
your emergency fund
step two pay off all debt using the debt
snowball
step three three to six months of
expenses
in savings step four invest fifteen
percent of household income
in roth iras and pre-tax retirement
step five college funding for children
step six pay off house early
step seven build wealth and give
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country or have a
better life
the army national guard can help get you
there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com to find out more
[Music]
our scripture of the day john 15 13
greater love has no one than this
that someone lay down his life for his
friends
abraham lincoln said honor to the
soldier and sailor
everywhere who bravely bears his
country's cause
honor also to the citizen who cares for
his brother in the field and serves
as best he can the same cause
happy veterans day to all of you
listening
today live that i have served or
are serving we appreciate you we salute
you at ramsay
we think you are the best of the best
yeah and uh
we really really appreciate you if you
are a business owner out there and you
want to grow your business you need to
start with the man in the mirror
i figured out years ago i'm the biggest
problem around here
therefore i am the biggest solution
around here
growing your business means growing
yourself as a leader and that's what
entre leadership summit is all about
entre leadership summit may
is coming up in 2021 may 16-19
here in nashville it combines a
world-class experience with
content that will get you fired up the
2021 speaker lineup
is absolutely world-class marcus
buckingham
best-selling author pat lincione
best-selling author
craig groeschel best-selling author
senior pastor of life
church let lifechurch.tv sinek
best-selling author of the book start
with why the latest is his infinite game
jim collins of course you know jim yeah
leadership expert best-selling author
many times over
including the classic good to great
christy wright chris hogan dr john
deloney ken coleman
and me we have less than 150 seats left
wow
so hurry and get yours for summit and
all you do is text
the word summit to 44 222
that's 44 to
arlington virginia is calling margarita
is on the line hey margarita how are you
hi dave anthony how are you guys doing
well great how can we help
so um i'm pretty new to your whole
program
um but i have a question about uh
student loans and property so a little
background my husband and i
uh we've been married for about a year
we're both 23 he works at a consulting
firm
and we both make about a hundred thirty
thousand after taxes
we have about eighty thousand in student
loans um
and our rent is about two thousand
dollars a month
um as you know arlington is pretty
expensive but we
really want to buy a house so i guess my
question is should we go about buying a
house first and looking in different
areas or should we tackle those
um student loans now yeah you're 80 k in
a hole right now so we're focusing on
the student loans
and i'm doing the math right now so you
have 80 000 student loans is that your
only debt
yeah okay cool so you make 130 000 net
you're spending about
um how much are you spending on rent
right now two thousand two thousand
right so you're spending twenty four
thousand dollars a year on rent another
ten thousand dollars in expenses so
doing the math you can honestly have
this paid off within about
18 months if you really aggressively go
at it and so now that's not bad now
you're in your 20s i don't know you've
been married
well this and the december is going to
be our one year anniversary
okay yeah yeah and so i that's the route
i'm going and i want to say this as a
young person
i didn't purchase my first house until i
was what maybe 32 day 30 32
and and i had the capabilities financial
capabilities to do it at about 28
but i said i wanted to do it right and
when i walked into my
house it was in a peaceful way and i was
not
wasting any money in my 20s renting
because i wasn't ready to purchase a
home margarita when i first got married
the first property that we rented
which is where you're living right now
uh
we rented way too expensive
arlington is expensive but you
rented too expensive a place for a
newlywed couple
okay yeah you got a nice place yeah
two thousand dollars i mean you really
do
and so you if i were you i would move uh
down in property so that i'm
paying less for my patients and i would
be debt-free in 18 to 24 months living
on a beans and rice rice and beans
budget
where your broke friends are making fun
of you
because if you try to keep up with the
joneses in dc
right you're going to be broke your
whole life troops
because the joneses in dc are nuts
so you just re i mean they're nuts it's
a whole
i mean it's l.a
l.a and dc the biggest put on the dog
world there is so you just got to say
we are 23 years old we're going to take
two years
and get out of debt and build an
emergency fund and we're gonna live
in a less than ideal
uh place for less than two thousand
dollars
and we're gonna pile up a big pile of
cash and then when we buy a house at 26
we're going to put down a huge down
payment and we're going to be in a whole
different place
than those yolo friends of ours who are
making fun of us
yeah because you know yolo is the new
way of saying
thank god it's friday oh god it's monday
right spend everything we make have no
money you make
good money you're in an expensive area
but this is very very doable it is
very unwise to buy a home where you have
to buy an extra bedroom for sallie mae
it's a really good idea to give her her
eviction notice while you're still a
renter
you're debt free you have an emergency
fund you move in with a good strong down
payment and then you can quote anthony
when i walked into the house there was a
sense of peace
sense of peace but if you move into a
house with an eighty thousand dollar
student loan
and you're 24 years old and you're 100
you've been married a year
year and a half at that point two years
and
you're broke but you make a hundred
thirty thousand dollars a year
what are you freaking congress yeah you
spend
everything you make and just to look
like you're not broke
yeah and you're you know i'll tell you
what will happen sally may move in the
bedroom
and three weeks later the heat and air
will go out on this new place and you'll
find out the difference between renting
and owning then is you get to do the
repairs you know what dave i get a lot
of pushback
uh from people who say you know what i'm
wasting money by renting and i'm wasting
money by paying off my student loans
waste your money we're paying off
student loans yes because they're like
well hey
warren's gonna pay them it goes back to
the government like why pay them if
they're gonna be forgiven and if they're
not required
to be paid right now why pay them
because they're not going to be forgiven
and you're going to be saddled with them
the rest of your life and they're the
major impediment between you and
building wealth there you go dave
that's the bottom line yeah i didn't see
you the problem with believing a fantasy
is
it'll screw up your finances yes sir and
when you believe dc is going to solve
your problem you have a huge problem if
you believe politics politicians of
either party are going to solve your
problem
then you have just condoned your
condemned yourself to a life of
mediocrity
right because i've been sitting around
waiting for people to send me money out
of dc for 60 years
i still hadn't got any me neither all
i've ever seen is they take money yeah
they don't give money they're a tick on
my butt yeah they're a parasite
unbelievable then on the flip side dave
um a lot of people think especially i'm
seeing this younger generation wanting
to jump into purchasing a home
but they're not in a position and ready
to purchase a home so someone becomes a
curse instead of a blessing there you go
dave i was just about to say that
i stole it i stole your lines gracious
dave
your dream becomes a nightmare here's
the thing
my generation i mean we've been married
uh
38 years yeah was the first generation
maybe my parents a little bit of that
generation was the first
generation to buy a home
within five years of marriage wow
up until the 19th and up until about
newlyweds did not consider buying a home
and no one in the culture
told them it was wise to buy a home they
all said
you just got married doofus shut up and
save money wow
wow it's going to you know it was it was
normally you were 30 years old
and you'd been married five or 10 years
before you could put together enough
cash to buy a home
but enter fha loans with three percent
down
yes enter va loans with zero percent
and enter this idea that home ownership
is always grand and it's not sometimes
it's 50 grand
it sure is and it doesn't it it'll break
your butt
when you buy a house and you're broke
it's a problem that's it dave
anthony good show hey thank you dave for
having me on james childs producer
great job kelly daniel associate
producer and phone screener i'm dave
ramsey your host we'll be back with you
before you know it
in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace
and that's to walk daily with the prince
of peace
christ jesus
[Music]
people call my show all the time
complaining
about how awful their shares are
and yet you guys have been really having
good success getting people
out of their time shares we have we kind
of helped create this industry
now there's a lot of exit companies out
there they come and they go
times sure extra team is different i
mean we we now have
you know almost 20 000 people out of
timeshare contracts
actual results actual results big deal
our guarantee is that if we can't get
you out of your timeshare we give you
your money back
hey if you need out timeshare exit
team is the team the only team
that i trust to help you schedule your
free consultation
by calling 844 999
exit or timeshare exit team.com
i made this many mistakes as far as
taxes were concerned
[Music]
and we wanted to do things correctly we
got very frustrated knowing that there's
got to be a better way to do this